Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pretlove. Und nachdem
Wer so viel Chorona hatten hier in den letzten äh Wochen und Monaten
wird's auch mal wieder Zeit, ein Blick in den Rest der Welt äh zu werfen und ich freue mich sehr, dass wir heute unsere tolle Brexit-Serie fortsetzen können und ich sage, hallo zu John.
Hallo mal wieder.
John John Worst äh ja, viele dürften dich jetzt hier schon kennen. Jetzt hatten wir mal wieder eine Pause trotz alledem. Kriegen wir's, glaube ich, so mehr oder weniger hin und zumindest alle drei bis vier Monate zu treffen, um ja diese Permated-Krise.
Genau.
Das Vereinigten Königreich zu beleuchten. Na ja und ist nicht viel besser geworden, oder?
Genau, also wir haben nicht so viele Vorträge gesehen, seit das letzte Mal, ja, ja. Aber gut, aber wir wissen jetzt, wie tief oder wie wie die Deutschen sagen, schlimmer geht immer, also das ist auf jeden Fall unser Slogan für Breakset.
Ja, trotz alledem wollen wir mal schauen, wir hatten jetzt unsere letzte Sendung am achtundzwanzigsten Februar, da war ja alles so ein bisschen schon gelaufen, sprich
der Austritt ist offiziell verkündet und abgesegnet und so weiter und äh.
Dann haben wir so ein bisschen einen Ausblick gemacht, was denn jetzt so kommen könnte, denn was ja ein Stand war, die Verhandlung mit der EU,
die hat's auch so ein bisschen gegeben, aber wie wir ja alle wissen, kam da noch ein bisschen was dazwischen und ähm ja, das hat äh ganz interessante Verwerfung nach sich gezogen. Ähm wie hast du denn die Zeit,
wahrgenommen, wie so die Gesellschaft sich so gefühlt hat nach der Wahl und dann natürlich auch nach dem erfolgten.
Brexit und derzeit danach, so, was, was war denn dann so der Konsens, wenn's überhaupteingab.
Also am am Anfang war es dann, also für Johnson, dein klar, okay?
Austritt kann jetzt stattfinden, der hat das dann durch den Partyman ohne großen Problemen gekriegt. Austritte folgte dann am einunddreißigsten.
Januar. Aber was er nicht wusste und wir immer noch nicht wissen, ist.
Wie soll dann dieses Brexit dann richtig aussehen.
Weil in in was man vorher den Austritts vertrag und die Ration verhandelt hat, also alle die Etappen vor Weihnachten.
War es dann nicht klar, wie sie die Zukunftsbeziehungen zwischen Großbritannien und die EU dann aus.
Es kam vor der Wahl, auch diese Diskussion, weil bei Johnson hat,
die äh die sogenannten ähm zu den die hin in Züge fügt. Also wie sehen dann die Beziehung zwischen,
England shoppen. Whey, so war eine Seite und Nordialand, auf der anderen Seite dann aus, also das waren dann die erste sehr große Frage. Weil da gab's Widersprüche innerhalb der Regierung auch während der des Wahlkampfs.
Die anderen Fragen waren nicht so wirklich im Fokus in diesen Monaten nach der Wahl und und um dieses Abstimmung in den Briten und Haus und den offiziellen Austritt am einunddreißigsten Januar,
die anderen Themenfelder rücken, dann immer mehr ins Fokus in den letzten,
äh paar Wochen, aber wir haben dann insgesamt keine kein großes Klarheit.
Was für auch danke sagen muss, ne. Also unser letztes Podcast war Ende Februar, also vor dem Beginn von Choronovirus, in in Großbritannien wirkt.
Das bedeutet, dass niemand hat in Großbritannien zwischen sagen wir so Mitte März und Mitte Mai.
Sich überhaupt mit Brexit dann beschäftigt. Also das war kein Thema für keine Politiker für die Regierung auch nicht. Ähm.
Michaebanie, der Chef und Verhandler auf der EU-Seite war selbst äh krank.
Äh Johnson auch auf der britischen Sache natürlich. Ähm wir wissen noch nicht, ob, ob ob Frost, der Hauptverhandler, auf der britischen Seite ähm Krone hatte, aber der war auch eine Walle krank.
Ähm und natürlich Verhandlungsrunden kann man auch so per Videokonferenz machen, aber mit also eine Intensivität, was man für solche Verhandlungen braucht. Es ist natürlich die sehr, sehr schwierig.
Das bedeutet, dass die ganze Zeit fahren, war schon problematisch, weil.
Brexit sollte schon äh März zwanzig neunzehn stattfinden, also man hat zehn Monaten schon verloren, weil das erfolgte erst Januar zwanzig zwanzig.
Und man hatte,
alle hatten Angst, gibt's genug Zeit, um eine zukünftige Beziehung zu verhandeln, zwischen März, zwanzig neunzehn und Ende zwanzig zwanzig, also was ist das denn, das ist äh einundzwanzig Monaten,
Aber für Johnson blieb dann nur elf Monaten übrig. Man hat Tanz zumindest zwei Monaten verloren, dank Kohonivirus. Also dieses Zeitschiene, dieses Alplan war so sehr schwierig schon.
Und der hat dann noch dazu zwei Monaten dann verloren. Also und,
wir wir sind jetzt nur ein bisschen über sechs Monaten vor der Ende der der sogenannten Übergangsperiode und wir haben ja keine Ahnung wie das dann.
Weitergehen soll. Wir wissen nur, dass die Uhr jetzt so wirklich tickt.
Wir haben ja heute, das habe ich noch gar nicht gesagt, den achtzehnten Juni und eigentlich
sind wir ja wieder kurz vor der nächsten Deadline, denn dieser Übereinkunft darüber,
denn diese Übergangsperiode gegebenenfalls noch verlängert werden soll, um maximal zwei Jahre. Diese Entscheidung sollte eigentlich jetzt bis Ende Juni getroffen sein.
Die Chancen sind,
null, das Großbritannien, die ähm diese äh die Regierung hat gesagt, letzte Woche diese Verlängerung wollen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht und nehmen wir nicht
Also was bedeutet, dass aus meiner Seite ich finde das vollkommen verrückt, aber,
das ist die Position der der britische Regierung. Also niemand in Brüssel,
Ohne in London, die Hoffnung, dass die Regierung entscheidet sich für eine Verlängerung der der übrigens Periode.
Und gibt es denn eine Chance, dass diese Deadline selber auch nochmal verrückt wird.
Also juristisch ist es schwierig, auf der auf der größere Seite, weil das ist in den Austrittsvertrag. Also man musste dann den Austrittsvertrag ändern, um dieses Datum,
so wir sind so verlängert oder zu ändern. Die Diskussion in Brüssel ist so eine Art,
Transischen, Autofahrt sicher oder so, einfach so, äh, dass man findet einen Weg irgendwie, dass in den gültigen
Vertragshut hin Zukunftsbeziehungen, es gibt diversen Deadlines da drinnen. Also das wäre,
Eine Alternative. Nicht, dass alles sich ändert von einem Tag bis den nächsten. Man muss,
dann ein bisschen weiterhin denken, warum will die britische Regierung auf keinen Fall.
Dann eine verlängerter Verhandlungsperiode. Ja, also das macht keinen Sinn. Wir haben keine großen Planen her, keine Zeit. Die EU sagt im Moment mal, also unser Fokus ist auf Chorona, also wir haben schon wirtschaftlichen äh Schäden.
Wäre das dann der nicht sinnvolle, das Ding einfach zu verlangen? Das ist alles wegen Parteipolitik. Und nur wegen Parteipolitik, weil es gab ein Deal.
Innerhalb der konservativen Partei? Ja, äh im November letztes Jahr.
Die Brexit Hardline zum Steve Baker, die wollen schon damals ein No-Deal Brexit. Na so, Brexit ohne eine äh Ei ein Vertrag.
Und dann ist gar aber eine Gurpe so von pragmatisieren, die haben sie sagt, ja, im Moment mal, so das ist hier edlich. Wir wollen dann doch eine Austrittsvertrag. Und in dieses Kompromiss war da, okay.
Wie wir so die radikalen, wir akzeptieren ein Brexit mit einem Vertrag,
aber nur unter den Bedingungen, dass es muss alles muss bis Ende zwanzig zwanzig erledigt werden,
Also das ist dann dieses historischen Kompromiss im November, Partei intern bei den. Ja, macht dieses Kompromiss überhaupt heutzutage sehen? Nein.
Aber, weil, was die konservative Hinterbankler hier wollen, ist Fast Boris Johnson hier tut,
das ist warum, dass es du dann weitergeht. Ja, die Welt hat sich, ihr seid eben geändert. Aber,
man kann auf keinen Fall Regierungsrasen dieser ähm Übergangsperiode verlängern. Also es ist für die Region.
Was dann wiederum bedeutet, dass auch die EU sich jetzt langsam mit diesem Gedanken äh anfreunden muss, dass es zu No Deal kommt.
Aber täpiger, die EU hat sich besser auf ein No Deal Szenario vorbereitet, als Großbritannien.
Wahlen zum Beispiel. Das war unter den verrückten in den letzten Wochen letzte Woche.
Großbritannien braucht fünfzigtausend neue Zollbeernte, um.
Einkommende Waren aus die EU an britischen Häfen zu kontrollieren. Es dauert ja eine Weile fünfzigtausend äh zur Beamte zu kontrollieren.
Und den sogenannten, also das sind so das Dachverband der Transportindustrie, LKW ein bisschen so, ja.
Rogistikindustrie. Ja, wie gesagt, Moment mal, also.
Was tun wir jetzt hier? Also wir müssen immer noch waren importieren. Wir haben nicht genug Leute, wir haben die Kontrollstelle nicht das das kann nicht gehen.
Und dann die Regierung, hey, ich sage, nö, also wir werden damals nicht alles kontrollieren können,
Hey, Moment mal, also, wie kann das doch gehen? Also, das wird die Regierung, also das war einfach Name von die britischen Grenzen, also das war,
Eins von den Hauptpunkten des Praxis. Und letzte Woche hat die Britscherin gesagt, nee, also,
die die meisten Kongresskontrollen oder Warenkontrollen, Sollkontrolle treten erst im Kraft sechs Monate danach.
Also das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Das ist so vollkommen eine Ehre, dass die das Land.
Die interessant das Austreten will, kann das nicht machen, aber dann Frankreich und die Niederländer Belgien haben gesagt, wir sind schon bereit
Also wir haben schon unsere Soulbeamter und wir haben unsere Kontrollstände. Die EU auf die EU-Seite von den von die Fähreverbindung. Alle steht schon
Und auf der britischen Seite nicht, obwohl dann die Brötchenbriten sagen, nein wir verlängen die die Übergangsperiode nicht.
Die Briten brauchen diese verlängerte Übergangspelge oder mal als die EU. Äh also das ist vor mir gerade stecken in dies diese verrückte Bad.
Ja, vor allem ist es ja auch mit diesen fünfzigtausend Beamten. Ich habe so eine Rechnung gesehen. Na ja, also es wurde ja auch immer beklagt,
Wir wollen uns ja nicht von ungewählten Bürokraten.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Ja, das war ja immer so eine Annektion. Das war ja sozusagen das Ding, das wird auch nochmal lustig, werden wir über Dominik Comings reden. Äh und ähm.
Wenn jetzt sozusagen tatsächlich diese fünfzigtausend Zollbeamten und das ist ja nicht nur Zollbeamte, sondern es ist ja sozusagen auch gesundheitstester, et cetera, also ein.
Agenturen, ne ja ja.
Müssen nur noch ganze Behörden aufgebaut werden. Wenn man also sozusagen all diese Leute dann beschäftigt, dann hat man mehr Bürokraten allein anstatt als die gesamte EU.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, genau, ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Ähm
bevor wir vielleicht zu weit nach vorne springen, müssen wir natürlich auch nochmal gucken, wie eigentlich diese Kovic, Katastrophe über Großbritannien eingebrochen ist. Wir hatten ja nun,
in allen Ländern so eine gewisse,
Reaktionsverzögerung und so eine Realitätsverweigerungshaltung. Das war, glaube ich, ganz normal für eine Region, die einfach mit Panemien so noch überhaupt gar keinen unmittelbaren Kontakt hat. Man hat zwar und das war vielleicht auch ein bisschen das Problem,
dadurch, dass Länder wie China auf eine gewisse Art und Weise, aber auch vom So teil waren, Südkorea,
all diese Erfahrungen schon hatten mit solchen Krisen und wussten in gewisser Hinsicht was zu tun ist, haben wir uns, glaube ich, so ein bisschen drauf ausgeruht, so nach dem Motto, na ja
das kriegen die schon hin, das kommt hier nicht her und,
ist nicht unser Problem. So, dann ging's halt irgendwie in Italien, los und alle so, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, die Abendmeta Jena. Bis man also geschnallt hat, dass das ja dann eigentlich schon direkt vor der Haustür ist und dann
so langsam gemerkt, in Österreich, ne, als direktes Nachbarland, Schweiz so, dann ging dann so langsam die Schotten runter, dann hat's nicht lange gedauert, bis dann eben auch in
Deutschland das Ding so ins Wallen kam, dann ging die Krise in Spanien äh äh richtig los und es war einfach der totale Alarm. Und man hat so den Eindruck, die Insel,
ist dann irgendwie immer noch so, ach ja für Kontinent haben wir ja nichts mit zu tun, ist ja ein Wasser dazwischen, was kann das schon passieren?
Ja. Es war sehr interessant, weil äh am Anfang so Großbritannien hat am Anfang der Kohlekrise gesagt, ja also wir sind ja ein paar Wochen vor Italien, hat die Regierung immer so gesagt.
Aber dann die Regierung hat nicht all nicht schnell genug
agiert, also Chorona war schon so weit verbreitet in Großbritannien. Dass man hatte dann eine enormen Wagstumanfällen sehr, sehr schnell in Großbritannien ganz am Anfan.
Und das Vatern auch,
irgendwie sehr interessant zu sehen, weil die so die Diskussion in Großbritannien war, so ein Log Downs, die wir dann gesehen haben, in viele andere Länder der der EU. Das akzeptieren die Briten nicht,
aber ohne Begründung, ja Deutschland hat er auch in in den letzten Jahrzehnten kein Lock da und so oder Italien oder oder Spanien auch nicht.
Und was wir da gesehen haben, also die Regierung hat Angst, also Moment mal, was du Tassen machst, das macht unsere Wirtschaft kaputt, wenn wir dann ein Log dann machen,
was die Nischtermikagle reincakuliert haben war, wenn wir, dass du spät machen, muss unser Logd da und deutlich heftiger
und länger dann sogar sein und länge dauern, als die da uns in andere Land, also Großbritannien, den Minus von den Wirtschaftswachstum, Großbritannien wird dann doch plus so viel sein, als in Deutschland, weil Großbritannien hat so lang gewartet, bis die das getan haben
Und dann dieses Log, dann ist ganz so viele Löcher so ja auch in dieses Log, ja. Ist jetzt immer noch kein Maskenfläche zum Beispiel im britischen Supermärkten.
Es gab, es gibt keine bei der Einreise, gab's an kein einziges Mal. Große Tannen haben versucht, gibt so ein, also den, in der ersten Patient, mit Krone, nee, die, die schätzen das
tausenddreihundert Leute mit mit Kona eingereist sind, in Großbritannien, weil die haben keine Kontrollen gemacht an der an den Flughäfen oder an den Häfen. Also das bedeutet, dass Großbritannien
hat sehr am Anfang sehr langsam.
Agiert. Die haben diese so Zeit Vorsprung, die die ja hatten überhaupt nicht effektiv dann äh verwendet.
Dann kommen dann auch dann natürlich hinzu, die sehr bekannten Problemen des Britchen. Gesundheitssystem, dass das unter finanziert ist,
es gab, es gibt auch enormen Problemen noch enormen Problemen,
in den Lieferketten von ähm äh sogenannten, also ähm Masken und, und, und anderen. Nee, nicht nur für Mitarbeiter in, in, in, in Krankenhäuser, sondern generell.
Altersheime auch.
Ja genau, also bei der war die gesamte Bewirkung. Also, wenn man ein Schutzmaske zu kaufen will, es ist nicht also einfach wie, wie wie in Deutschland oder in Frankreich.
Es gibt ja auch jetzt äh interessanten Untersuchungen, dass die ähm wie die Briten äh diese Verträge,
ausgegeben haben. Es gab ja Korruption,
in die auch in die Aufteilung von dieser ähm äh von von dieser Verträge. Weil es gibt sogar Produzenten von von Schutzmasken, Schutzkleidung in Großbritannien,
aber diese Firmen haben keine Verträge in Großbritannien gekriegt, sondern alles an anderen europäische Länder geliefert, weil die anderen Länder waren einfach schneller, die die Verträge zu geben für die Produktion von diesen Waren,
Ähm also das bedeutet, dass dieses fundamentale.
In Kompetenz, die es gab, während dem Brexit-Verhandlungen aha, hat die Britchior-Regierung einfach so dann weitergeführt.
Und was wir auch gesehen haben, ist seit jetzt seit Jahrzehnt ähm Verantwortung für ähm Gesundheitspolitik,
ist jetzt ein Themenfeld für die notierische, valistische und schossische Regierungen,
Und ja, es gab ja Problemen. Besonders immer etwas weniger in Schottland und in Nordirland. Aber die Reaktionen in dieser Länder waren ganz anders, aus in England,
Ja, also zumindest die die Auswirkungen auf die britische Gesellschaft. Und auch jetzt, wenn es kommt, zum möglichen Locherungen,
sagen, hey Moment mal so, wir haben immer noch weit zu vielen äh Fällen. Also wir müssen ganz vorsichtig ran
Und die britische Regierung schaut nur auf den wirtschaftlichen Zahlen und wäre san unmöglich schnell in Richtung Lochungen oder lockerungen gehen.
Also genauso wie in den USA.
Ja genau. Ähm also es herrschen dann ein großes Streit
zwischen London und KFB und äh und. Also das ist dann auch sehr interessant zu beobachten, weil die briche Regierung,
spricht wie eine Regierung für die das gesamte Land, aber viel an Aspekten von im Bereich der Gesundheitspolitik sind nicht mehr national, sondern sind auch in Großbritannien regionalisiert.
Ich habe den Clip ja jetzt gerade nicht zur Hand, aber ich wurde von einem Hörer darauf hingewiesen, dass als wir letztes Jahr über
Die möglichen Auswirkungen gesprochen haben und wie sehr das auch wirtschaftlich äh äh eine Schwächung sein könnte. Ich dann gesagt habe, na ja, könnte er sein, dass vielleicht mal wieder so eine, so eine Panthemie kommt
ernsthaft. Und der Edit ist dann auf einmal eine wichtige Rolle spielt, weil ich glaube, wir hatten darüber gesprochen, wie äh sehr da die Debatte schon äh darum ging, dass nicht, es gibt ja diese ähm der rote Bus äh sage ganz
Brexit Kampagne. Ja, dreihundertfünfzig Millionen gehen pro Woche äh an die EU, das können wir ja auch dem NHS geben, aber letzten Endes
ja, scheint das alles nicht passiert äh zu sein.
Aber wir müssen kurz kurz sagen, die die hat,
obwohl, es ist, es gibt ganz, ganz viele Toten beide. Aber wir müssen sagen, die selbst, aus Gesundheitsdienst hat diese Situation die Kohlevirus besser überlebt,
aus wie Dachen, weil alle anderen, ja, für keine Ahnung äh,
alles andere, was ein Gesundheitssystem tut, die haben alles andere so reduziert
um genug Kapazitäten vorher für Covic-Patienten zu schaffen. Also das bedeutet, das am Anfang, man hat Angst, dass das britische Gesundheitssystem wäre total überfordert, ja,
das war es eigentlich nicht. Also am Ende, es gab genug Ventilatoren zum Beispiel, das soll das war aber am Anfang die Frage, gibt's ja genug Ventilatoren für die Kovic-Patienten? Ja, es gab ja genug
Aber die CD Zahlen der Toten in Großbritannien waren enorm hoch
Also, aber das war da nicht irgendwie, das ist irgendwie sehr interessant, weil die, das Gesundheitssystem war selbst nicht überfordert, haben die Anzahl an Thronen war enorm hoch im Vergleich zu anderen europäischen Ländern.
Ja. Also ich glaube, mein Kommentar war in dem Moment auch mehr, so, dass sich eben diese politische Debatte auf einmal verschieben kann, zum Beispiel auf ein medizinisches Problem. Und genau das ist ja nun letzten Endes äh pass,
Ich deute das mal eher jetzt als äh Zufall. Aber vielleicht kannst du nochmal erklären,
welche Bedeutung dieser National Health Service in der Gesellschaft hat, weil es scheint ja.
Es ist anders gesehen zu werden oder zumindest eine besondere Rolle zu haben, äh so wie wir jetzt hier so von unserem Gesundheitssystem nicht sprechen.
Sorry es ist eine sehr interessanter und sehr schwierige Frage. Am Anfang, man muss.
Man muss darüber denken, dass.
Ganz, ganz viele Briten haben fast keine Erfahrungen von anderen Gesundheitssystem. Und wenn die Erfahrung haben oder Schlagsein gesehen haben, so irgendeine Gesundheitssystem, das ist dann die amerikanische System.
Das brutschte Gesundheitssystem hat einem Plus. Man muss nie irgendeine Rechnung sehen,
oder bezahlen? Oder,
irgendeinem Beitrag für das Gesundheitssystem bezahlen, ja? Ich bezahle mein, mein Beitrag jeden Monat, zu meiner Krankenkasse in Deutschland und das ist grob, wie viel.
Theoretisch, das ist dann meinen Beitrag zu den Gesundheitssystemen. Also, das sehen die Briten nicht. Also, das das ist, das ist generell so Steuerfinanziert,
Und das mögen die Briten, dass wenn ich krank bin, ich kann zu meinem
äh Hausarzt gehen, umsonst, wenn ich in ein Krankenhaus behandelt werden muss.
Das geht dann auch umsonst. Ähm also das ist den Kern plus von dieses System.
Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt's enormen Problemen. Erstens, die war die Wartezeiten sind enorm hoch.
Zweitens Wupp für Prozideren, die dann ähm nicht so eine Martrop Life in Deads sind, so nicht so eine äh Todesfrage sind. Da geht's enorme Verzögerungen,
Und weil es auch Steuerfinanziert ist. Das britsche Gesundheitswesen ist enorm unterfinanziert, im Vergleich zu anderen,
euer europäische Länder, also zum Beispiel Deutschland hat Pro Kopf fünfmal so viele intensiv Stationen pro Kopf aus,
Großbritannien, aber auch Italien hat dreimal so viele Intensivstationen pro Kopf als als Großbritannien. Also das bedeutet, dass.
Also du meinst Betten, ne? Also.
Bei der Intensiven.
Also, das bettet, das dieses Fokus in Großbritannien ist immer, auf diese Frage, dass es umsonst ist für die, für britische Staatsbürger.
Die Debatte ist nicht wie soll das Gesundheitssystem selbst dann aussehen und es heißt.
Hellservice. Ja, so eine gesundheitsservierst. Aber es ist irgendwie.
Es ist gut für die sehr kranke Menschen. Wenn ich jetzt heutzutage super krank bin, dann ist es dann okay,
Aber wenn ich etwas brauche für meine langfristige Gesundheit, ja, Physiotherapie zum Beispiel. Also, diese Aspekten sind enorm unzufinanziert, im Vergleich zu der Situation in Großbritannien. Und.
Es hat auch,
sehr wichtige Historische Wurzeln. Das ist eine, dass diese die die jetzigen Form des Naschen, so free up point devery, also diese, das ist ansonsten.
Äh ist auch so Ende der Vierziger. Also diese legendäre Label-Region unter einen legitären Gesundheitsminister Neuren Bevan. Also, ähm, ein felisischer Politiker. Und das war so den Aufbau des Sozialstaats in Großbritannien
in den Nachkriegsjahren.
Und diese Nashalt-Service ist so ein Zeichen von diese so gesellschaftliches Zusammenhalt Großbritanniens.
Das stimmt ja nicht so ganz, weil es gibt natürlich eine Parallele
Gesundheitssystem, ja, die private Gesundheitssystem so fünf bis zehn Prozent, die sie erreichen, die verwenden den Naschenheal Service nicht. Also, es gibt eine separate, privates System
Aber irgendwie, dass es ein Teil von diese so Methos von das so, dass dieses Zusammenhalt
Großbritanniens. Also, dass darf man in die britische Politikdebatte nie in Frage stellen. Also die das finde ich.
So sehr es ist so sehr begrenzt. Ich weiß nicht, was dem besten Modell ist. Aber was ich zumindest weiß, ist für.
Dingen, die die so kann er so live und der Fragen sind, ist die Situation aus meinem Süß zumindest in Deutschland, deutlich besser
Ja, also dieses so, alles war um den Gesundheitssystem. Ja, also das ist um ein Gesundheit nicht, wenn ich echt krank bin, dass ich nicht sterbe
Ja. Ähm
und aber aus meinem meinem Eindruck ist, dass die meisten Briten haben so wenig Erfahrung von anderen Systemen, dass die sehe nicht, dass anderen europäische Länder, ja, natürlich die Situation in Deutschland, nur den Frankreich, oder Italien ist kein Paradies, aber
diese Gesundheitssystem tun manche Dingen sogar besser als aus in Großbritannien. Ähm aber dass das
sehen die Briten nicht, wir stehen die Briten nicht, also man darf diese sozusagen werden, also da das ist wie wie die Debat.
Ne, stellt er. Ja dadurch, dass es Steuer finanziert ist, ist es natürlich extrem den politischen Willen ausgese,
Und das, denke ich mal, ist jetzt hier so ein bisschen das Problem. Grundsätzlich ist die Idee für die ist ja eine tolle äh äh toller Ansatz so,
gewisser Hinsicht. Na ja, free, also zumindest nicht.
Dass man nicht pro Behandlung bezahlt und vor allem nicht unbedingt jetzt mehr bezahlt, wenn wir hatten diese Fälle in in den USA, wo dann Leute irgendwie nur ein Test bekommen haben oder äh ja, vielleicht sogar auch mit Gruppe behandelt worden und dann irgendwie
Rechnungen hatten den Größenordnung, die einfach äh,
jenseits von gut und böse waren, das gibt's halt dann auch in UK nicht, aber ist natürlich klar, dass wenn jetzt die Politik
mit äh so einem Public Service nicht so viel anfangen kann. Das Geld lieber woanders hinleiten möchte, ist dann eben auch tut. Und das ist eigentlich das, was die Torys auch getan haben in der letzten Zeit, oder?
Genau, das stimmt und auch, obwohl es für die.
Obwohl es für so die die Bürger kostenlos ist. Gab es ja eine enorme Enthüllung,
der äh von den Systemen in den Gesundheitssystemen so hinter den Kulissen teilweise eine Privatisierung und einem Abbau von den Systemen,
Also zum Beispiel Großbritannien hat noch ein Problem mit,
ähm zum Beispiel. Es gab eine riesen Debatte, in so einen Monat lang, dass Großbritannien brauchte hunderttausend poronerte Tests am Tag
ja? Und Deutschland hat sogar fünfhundert, einige Passität von fünfhunderttausend Tests am Tag. Ähm weil.
Die Systemen hatte Großbritannien einfach so aus, die die Laboren geschlossen, alles auf den Kompabs minimum reduziert,
Ja? Ähm und dann, wenn man hat so eine Krise und und man hat
man hat keinen so süßessichen Kapazitäten in dem System. Ah ja, er reicht man dann sehr schneller, ein Problem. Und zum Beispiel mit Truck and Trace, also Großbritannien hat immer noch keinen richtigen Truck Trace, wie den noch mit so einen,
basierten, aber auf Papierbasiertensystem oder per Telefon oder keinen funktionsfähigen Ab, weil Großbritannien hat kein Test, äh macht
nicht genug Tests, hat kein System, dass man schnell genug die Testergebnisse kriegt. Also man hat keine Daten, die man überhaupt dann in einen guten Abverwenden kann,
also hat nicht sogar den Startpunkt erreicht für einen funktionsfähigen Virus ab. Weil die Systemen funktionieren so miteinander nicht mehr.
Und das ist wegen dieses Enthüllung der der Funktionen des Staats.
Und das ist dann auch dann ein Teil von diese ganzen ist einfach mal ist das britische Staat überhaupt in der Lage irgendwas so,
so organisieren, ja? Kann das die britische Staat fünfzigtausend Zollbeamte überhaupt,
das ist meine ähnliche, enorme Herausforderung, wie hunderttausend Kohlevirus Test am Tag. Und die Regierung zumindest. Scheint nicht in der Lage, sowas so groß ist
überhaupt hinzukriegen.
Schauen wir nochmal konkret darauf, wie äh jetzt die Regierung mit der Krise am Anfang umgegangen ist. Also das ist eine späte Reaktion gab es ja jetzt allgemein
bekannt haben wir jetzt hier auch schon angesprochen. Es kam, glaube ich, in den letzten Wochen auch noch ähm die Informationen heraus, dass tatsächlich nach der Wahl von
äh Boris Johnson so ziemlich mit einer der ersten Tätigkeiten, die glaube ich die Regierung überhaupt vorgenommen hat, sie
die Pathemiekommission aufgelöst haben, die es äh schon seit vielen Jahren gab. Vom Timing her könnte man ja nicht schlechter liegen.
Wie werden denn solche Informationen in der Öffentlichkeit dort aufgenommen? Also replitiert das noch jemand oder geht das alles in so einem Nachrichtenbrei unter.
Also es gab so vielen schlechten Schlagseilen in den letzten zwei Monaten für die Region. Es war eine Reihe von.
Katastrophen. Also äh das ist nur eine Katastrophe und äh,
in eine riesen Liste. Man muss nicht vergessen, dass in dem.
Am Anfang hat man so gedacht, die Regierung, die Reaktion der Regierung war vielleicht am bisschen so langsam,
aber die gehen irgendwie mit eine klare Strategie voran, irgendwie, also so war die erste Reaktion.
Anfang Brille, also oder Mitte April war Boris Johnson und die so poppiolär wie noch nie.
Ja, also auch nach der Beginn der Krise, also wir gehen, wir haben einen Plan plant, wir bon Notunterkünfte für Patienten auf.
Auch die Briten haben sonst mehr oder weniger gut akzeptiert. Wir machen täglichen Pressekonferenzen über der der Lage der der Depandemie so berichten.
Die haben so zumindest einen halbwegs fegen Eindruck gegeben. Aber seitdem,
und besonders in den letzten vier, fünf Wochen alles bricht auseinander. Also wir haben gesehen, dass hinter den Kulissen, die hatten ja keinen Plan
ja, dass die dieses dieses Schlag sein, dass die haben, die die dieses Ausschuss abgebaut
Es gab auch Probleme mit die Saison an. Also das ist so ein Ausschuss von von äh Wissenschaftler, die müssen dann die Regierung dann beraten, aber wir haben dann gesehen, dass auch,
so politische Berater der Regierung sitzen da drinnen, es gibt natürlich den enormen Problem, dass,
äh weil die nicht genug Tests ausgeführt haben und die wollten die die Prozentzahl der der,
äh dete Betten in in Krankenhäuser, die mit Patienten voll waren, stark reduzieren.
Um Platz für Kovic-Patienten zu schaffen, die haben viele sehr alte Menschen, die.
Offiziell nicht Patienten waren, so zu Autosheimen,
zurückgeschickt, ja? Und da viele davon haben dann Co wieder, aber weil es nicht nur äh gab
die haben diese Menschen nicht getestet, vor die dann aus Krankenhäuser dann zurück so Altersheimen geschickt haben. Es gab
tausende Toten in in ähm in Altersheime. Ich denke, die Zahl erreicht über ein Drittel der Kovitote in Großbritannien, war eine Alte Menschen in Hausesheime.
Also so eine enorme Liste von katustrophalen Entscheidungen manchmal.
So sehr ernsthafte und, oder fehlhafte Entscheidungen. Und manchmal echt.
Verrückte Entscheidungen oder und diese äh diese äh Woche, so als tausend eine Woche, dieses Skandal, um Dominik Coming zum Beispiel hat.
Hat die Regierung enorm viel anglaubwürdigkeit gekostet.
Reden wir gleich mal drüber, ähm zunächst einmal war es ja dann so auch noch das Bonus-Johnson in
Anfang dieser Krise in Krankenhäusern rumlief
sich mit äh Kuvic Patienten unterhalten hat, keine Maske getragen hat, nicht nur das äh vor dem Mikrofon stand und damit angegeben hat, dass er ja hier allen die Hand schütteln würde und ist ja überhaupt äh
Ja, bitte gehen sie weiter. Es gibt nichts äh zu sehen. Paar Wochen später hat er dann selber sich den Virus,
eingefangen, nicht nur das, sondern wird auch noch richtig krank, kommt sogar auf die Intensivstation für ein, zwei Tage, wird dort von EU Migranten, Leuten, die in Manages arbeiten,
pflegt und überlebt das Ganze, obwohl er wohl wirklich weiß ich genau wie krank er jetzt letztlich wirklich war, aber er war.
Und wir wissen aus Regierungskreisen, da arbeitet immer noch nicht zu hundert Prozent. Ja. Aber.
Das ist ja tippisch für Boris Downson. Also der der.
Der kann nicht ernsthaft arbeiten. F versteht.
Das einfach nicht, ja? Er kann es ist gegen sein ganzes Willen irgendwie.
Er weiß nicht, was man tut. Gut mit einem ernsthaften Situation um sie gehen. Er kriegt das einfach nicht hin. Ja. Ähm.
Wir haben in den letzten Wochen so gesehen, er liest oft die Papiere nicht.
Die sein Team ihm vor wichtigen Treffen gebe.
Ich ich wir wissen ja nicht, aber es wäre nicht erstaunlich vor dieses Krankenhausbesuch am sechsten März, also er hat dann danach gesagt, ja, ich habe die halt das Handgeschüttel von alle Menschen.
Bestimmte gab es ein Papier vor vor dieses Besuch.
Sie müssen niemanden befassen. Oder so, auf der Fettperson, in so sechsunddreißig Point groß, rot, auf seinem Papier.
Ohne eine Hand ist einfach nicht gelesen, ja. Ich find's unglaublich, das Beispiel vor der Wahl.
Der der stellvertretende Botschafter Großbritanniens ist an an dem Tag vor ein Fernsehdebatte zurückgetreten.
Nur ein Beispiel von nichts nimmt.
Diese Frau hieß Alexandra, also die hat die gleiche Nachname zweimal. Ich muss das cool und so, aber also irgendein Fehler in den Medienbericht, als ich so herrlich.
Und dann kriegt Boys Johnson die Frage. Wie war die ähm stellvertretende Botschaft der Großbritanniens in Washington DC? Sie ist am Tag vor im Fernsehen Debatte so gedreht, wegen die Problemen wegen Brexit.
Und dann gibt's schon so die Fragen, diese Fernsehdebatte. Ja, ähm, was halten sie von den von den Stellvertretenden auf den Washington DC? Und dann antwortet, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Hat eine geantworte.
Also äh wie kann das sein? Ist er entweder sein Team ist so blöd, dass sie haben das nie stehen den Briefing reingeschrieben? Oder der hat den Briefing nicht,
geschrieben, gelesen. Oder der hat das gelesen, hat das nicht kapiert, kann irgendwas in sein Gehirn nicht irgendwie behalten, ja,
unerzählt dann so ein Blödsinn. Also, das bedeutet, dass so.
So, dass er schon den Hand von Kovic Patienten, ja, das ist so vollkommen voll im Charakter von Boris Johnson, ja? Es nimmt nichts ernst. Also, das bedeutet, dass.
Dann, wenn man braucht, ja, und du auch, denn es ist, es wäre zu lesen. Ah, ist immer wert zu lesen, Wasser schreiben. Macht die Dank Cola, das ist eine ein, so ein Journalist, vorher,
Partei nah bei den Konservitäten, also immer Saison so auf der rechten Seite, ihr habt den Britchen im politischen Spektrum.
Das so berichtet, also und Leute gefragt, wie schlimm war es so in in der Regierung, als Boris Johnson im Krankenhaus schon? Ja, so, alle hatte viel Angst, weil man wusste nicht,
wie das weitergehen soll. Aber was für ein Einfluss hatte das auf die Supanimiebekämpfern? Fast keine Auswirkung.
Weil er.
Ey, er hat dann keine Kontrolle. Ja, oder er kümmert sich nicht überhaupt umnimmt, um den Details. Und das bedeutet, der Machtdanischständig, enorme Fehler.
Also äh er war äh es, es gibt diese sogenannten, also das ist in die Vorsitzende von aller Ausschüssen des des Britchen und Hauses.
Die treffen ein alle sechs Monaten mit dem Premierminister. Die haben dann eine Version jetzt diesmal Personen gemacht, vor ein paar vor ein paar Monaten.
Und die haben dann Johnson ganz einfache Fragen gestellt. Hatte nur Ahnung. Er hat der geil, so das zum Beispiel, ist auch ein Problem, wenn Covic das.
Leute, die nicht aus EU-Länder in Großbritannien leben. Also und die haben ein Arbeitsvisum, die du, die dürfen
Keine Staatshilfen beantragen, also null
Ja, also arbeitslosen Geld oder oder für die Kinder und so weiter. Kriegen die nicht,
Aber natürlich, also diese Leute,
ist in Großbritannien, man hat keinen Job mehr, weil Auaba ist losig Couch, die enorm wegen Krone Virus. Man darf das Land nicht verlassen, weil das Land, wo vor, wovon man herkommt, verbietet Einreisende aus Großbritannien,
Kinder haben keine Schule, kriegen kein Essen, man hat kein Geld, man hat keine Staatshilfen, was kann man dann tun.
Und ja, die Abgeordneten haben Boys Johnson so, einer ist auch einfachen Fragensteller. So, was tut man für solche Menschen? Ja aber ich wünsche dir das Problem nicht,
Ja, warum können die keine Staatshilfen kriegen? Ja, weil die dürfen nicht, weil die konservativen haben, dass Verboten, ja, es war nicht stolz, dass Regierung, sondern der Regierung von von Carmen und von May, die das verkürzt haben.
Er hat keine Antwort. Also was bedeutet, es ist so, er ist so unglaublich schlecht vorbereitet.
Seit immer in seine ganze politische Karriere, der könnte mit Witze oder unseriöse Sprüche irgendwie so rüberkommen.
Und jetzt das schafft das nicht mehr.
Dass er das nicht mal hier mehr mir hinkriegt. Herrscht an Opposition geben gegen ihm,
und dahinter, weil die sind ja vielleicht konservativ oder sogar für den Brexit,
Arme, die sind ja nicht alle doof und die haben auch ja,
mit Wähler, in deren Wahlkreise. Und dieser Wähler werden echt sauer, wegen diese ganze Spielerei in der Regierung. Und diese Idee, dass die Regierung nimmt dieses die Krise, die beiden Krisenbrexit und,
und Tohone, nicht ernst. Es kam gestern dieses Idee aus.
Äh dass die die dieses ähm ähm ähm äh Regierungsflugzeug für für die Nauer, Auslandsreisen von, von, von Johnson. Der ist ja grau
Ja, das ist eine ehemalige Militärflugzeug. Das Ding ist einfach so mittelgrau.
Aber das gibt uns nicht den richtigen äh Eindruck. Wir werden das mit mit Unionsbilder dann so mit mit so einer ähm äh
wie heißt das Ding so? Was was Autos, weil eine Mamas ging äh Dingens.
Kostet neunhunderttausend Pfund das Ding, ja, weil ich will einen optimistischen Eindruck machen, wenn ich, dann so Auslandsreisen mache, in die nein, die in die hey Moment mal, ja, also
Golfmatanin steckt mit Nina eine riesen Krise,
ja, der hat ein, da hat ein etwas für totale Damen und das Ding war so imko rennt das, das könnte auch Boris Johnson sein. Ähm.
Über das, wir müssen unbedingt den Statue von Wincon Churchel aus Palence Brennes in Fern, ja? Niemand will dieses Tattoo entfernen, ja, die haben das Ding nur geschutzt, wegen die die diversen Demonstrationen. Ey so.
Alles wahr.
Wollt ihr nicht auch noch ein neues Schiff bauen.
Ja, die die haben kann keinen Vertrag dafür,
gegeben. Aber Großvitannien hat keine Werfte mehr, also ich weiß nicht, wo die das dann bauen lässt. Also vielleicht die, die Haare vielleicht doycay Deutschland den Vertrag,
So, die bauen das im Wilhelmshaven oder oder Cuxhaven oder irgendwo.
Schade, könnte schwierig werden mit den Importzellen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Lass uns nochmal einen Blick werfen auf die anderen wichtigen Akteure im äh
im Kabinett, beziehungsweise in der aktuellen Regierung, insbesondere natürlich den schon erwähnten Dominik Comings. Also man hat jetzt
in dieser ganzen Krise in den letzten Monaten, außer Johnson, der eigentlich immer nur so eine Kasperrolle zu spielen scheint
viel ja dann sozusagen auch äh das Licht sehr viel mehr auf seine Minister. Da gab's dann zunächst einmal Dominik Grab, der Außenminister ist, den irgendwie auch glaube ich noch keiner so richtig zur Kenntnis genommen hat
der äh hat ihn dann halt offiziell vertreten. Also hat diese Pressekonferenzen gemacht, aber ansonsten keinerlei,
Aktivität äh äh entwickelt, zumindest war das so meinen Eindruck. Ähm,
Mit Hankock, der Gesundheitsminister, der auch eher oder fahrenden Eindruck äh äh macht und mit im Handing dieser ganzen Krise jetzt auch nicht äh besondere Lobeshimmen erhalten hat.
Aber es gibt zwei Leute, die im Hintergrund zu stehen scheinen, die.
Die eigentlich treiber von allem zu sein scheinen. Da ist halt auf der einen Seite Michael Golf. Äh dessen offizielle Rolle jetzt gerade was eigentlich ist.
Der ist offiziell und hat die komplette Zuständigkeit für Brexit Planung.
Und natürlich der sagenumwobene Dominik Carmings, der keine Ministerrolle hat, sondern offiziell nur ein Berater,
von Boris Johnson ist und man musste Dominik Comings äh wissen, er war derjenige, der die Liefkampagne im Brexit-Referendum angeführt hat, ähm wo er auch schon von ähm,
Dominik Batch.
Doku Filme, Dokufilme über den äh Brexit. Also er war in gewisser Hinsicht der Öffentlichkeit
schon irgendwie bekannt, trotzdem gelingt es ihm immer so ein bisschen im Hintergrund zu bleiben, weil er sich eben nicht unbedingt so in die erste Reihe drängt, sondern seine Aktivitäten im Hintergrund macht. Aber er gilt halt gemeinhin so als als Drahtzier,
Wie schätzt du jetzt die so Rolle dieser dieser Leute äh ein und dann müssen wir natürlich auch um diesen.
Skandal in den Dominik Comings äh gerutscht ist, nochmal reden, weil offensichtlich scheint er sich ja immer angesteckt zu haben. Und hatte dann auch die Krankheit.
Also was Jutta hat gerade gesagt hast, ist sehr wichtig. Also,
Johnson hat dieses Mannschaft.
So im Downing Street sowie du vereint. Das bedeutet Johnsons Premierminister Gove, der, der seid über ein Jahrzehnter, der Abgeordnete ist, also der ist auch zumindest.
Ein Politiker, ja, der ist.
In den Details deutlich besser als Johnson, der ist auch aus meiner Sicht gefährlicher und intelligenter, als Johnson, der ist.
Ein bisschen langweilig, muss man sagen, also das bedeutet, dass er kann.
Oder hat vorher gegen sowas kandidiert hat. Oh, ab, oh, oder wollte damals Parteichef werden, kann es kriegt das nicht hin, der ist nicht so der der überzeugendste Mensch.
In in Wasseröffentlich sagt.
Da hat kein Carres mal.
Ja, wenn ich Charisma, ja. Ähm, Dana, mein Comings, man hat die ganze Leute, die, die macht das Medienarbeit, ähm äh für für Nombatan. Also,
Es gibt ein ganzes Team, die haben das ganze Ding, so wieder so, wie diese zweitausendsechs seine Kampagne in Downing Street dann wieder vereint.
Boris Johnson in seinem Kabinett hat faktisch niemanden mitwegsfähig ist.
Alle, die einige Kenntnisse haben oder irgendwie selbst,
einen halbwegs kompetenten Ruf haben, ja,
also zum Beispiel Hand, ist ein Gegner in die letzte Runde, für die ähm als konservative Parteivorsitzende eine, ich der war jahrelang, Gesundheitsminister, der war auch eine Wahlaußenminister.
Der, es wäre jetzt klug jemand, wie ihm so haben oder Gregpark, der ehemalige Industrieminister oder,
äh der der weil der,
Porrise Johnson, mir mochte da die Berater nicht. Und ja, vielleicht gesagt, okay, es ist entweder mal ich behalte meinen Berater oder ich drehe zurück und dann ist dann zurückgetreten.
Der einzige mögliche Star in dieses Kabinett ist im neuen Finanzminister.
Der ist echt clever, in so einem sehr so konservativen Bankermäßiges Art und Weise, aber der kann der kann gut reden, der präsentiert sich super gut,
und im Vergleich zu den anderen Akteure der gibt zumindest den Eindruck, dass er hat ein bisschen Ahnung von was er dann tut.
Aber das bedeutet, dass.
Dieses Kabinett von Johnson ist enorm schwach. So das bedeutet, dass dieses Kernteam von Johnson Comingson Gove, die haben die Kontrolle über,
alles. Ja, also das hat für die Brexit Kampagne relativ gut funktioniert,
die haben relativ gut verstanden, wie man so eine Kampagne mit so eine Cam Team leitet.
Aber eine Kampagne so organisieren, ist anders als wie man eine Regierung.
Liken muss. Und dieses Unterschied haben die aus meines ich nicht so wirklich verstanden. Das Ding ist irgendwie.
Und um mit diese ganze bekommen dann zu den Coming Skandal. Also Dominik Comings ist dann,
hat dann entschieden, Start in so eine innere, in eine Quarantäne in seinem Haus in London zu bleiben, dann einfach dann nach ähm äh nach ähm zu fahren, also fast vierhundert Kilometer nur nicht von London.
Der war.
Der harte Kovic, Symptome, seine Frau hatte auch Kovicsymptome seiner alte Eltern, da in Derry gehörte, so eine Risikogruppe.
Ähm die haben dann ständig auch dieses die die Geschichte geändert, der hat zuerst gesagt, ja ich ich wollte Hilfe von meiner Eltern,
weil die haben ja einen jungen Sohn mit die Kinderbetreuung Hilfe von den Eltern,
das war natürlich gegen die, die die Richlinien war dann, die haben dann dieses diese äh diese Geschichte dann geändert.
Und dann es gab natürlich dann diese echt verrückte Situation. Erst dann nach so einer kleinen Stadt äh etwa achtzig Kilometer von Derem gefahren,
um also puffen, ob ob er ähm überhaupt in der Lage war, nach London äh zu fahren, am Tag danach.
Das war wirklich der Brille, weil er hat ja dann so eine, eine, eine merkwürdige Pressekonferenz.
Äh gegeben, ja, wo er da irgendwie etwas die platziert, wie so wie so ein Montip heißen Sketch, sah das irgendwie aus. So saß er da hinter diesem kleinen und äh
ja, dann hat er halt versucht, sich da irgendwie rauszureden und man hat auch gemerkt, warum er in der zweiten Reihe steht, weil das einfach irgendwie nicht unbedingt jetzt so seine Rolle ist so, ne.
Sehr ungefährlich rüber,
und auch irgendwie wie viele Josten, dass sie gesagt hat man hatte eine Reihe von Sachen oder von.
Und hat dann versucht so eine Geschichte zu erzählen,
die passte dann zu den vorhandenen Fakten. Ah, Moment mal, jemand habe ich dann im Bahner Kassel gesehen. Dann okay, was für eine Begründung ist Akzeptan? Ja, die Brühen war ähm die Frau ist das Vater, das Geburtstag von die Frau von Dominik Counings.
Also, es ging nicht um, um, um, um zu sehen, ob, ob er überhaupt fahren könnte.
Und das waren so vierzig Kilometer oder sowas. Also es war jetzt.
Ja, es war ein schönes Ausflug auf Daram, ja. Äh so, ey. Aber.
Und dann natürlich auch die die zwei so ähm.
Polizei, System, den Großeltern, das so eine regionale Verantwortlichkeit. Und dieses Polizei von den Regionen von Deram, also County Derry Please,
die wollten gar nichts damit zu tun, ja. Wir haben das geprüft, wenn wir das gesehen hätte oder das
gestoppt hätte, können wir ihm sagen, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das darfst du nicht machen, also so nach Hause bitte. Aber die londen Polizei hat sich auch nicht darüber gekümmert, weil die wollen sich mit solche Dingen überhaupt nicht beschäftigen. Wir wissen, äh hat das Recht,
nicht eingehalten, ja, aber wir können wickeln gar nichts tun. Also wie, wie kann man dann? Boris Joneson überhaupt um zu durchsetzen,
Ja, wir haben gesehen, es gab einen enormen Verlust an Unterstützung für ihm und seine Regierung. Aber er hat sowieso ein Mehrheit von achtzig Sitzen im Brittchen unteraus. Soll das bedeutet, irgendwie.
Aber das ist, wo wo ich jetzt die Situation hat sich irgendwie geändert.
Johnson braucht Comings, weil um ein bisschen Disziplin.
Für seine Regierung so geben. Also, der ist, ich bin der Meinung, dass das Comings ist nicht all so klug, wie er selbst denkt und wie seine Verteidiger,
auch sagen, dass so diese riesen Gehören, dass er alles oder überstratege, nein,
das ist er nicht. Das wissen wir, die Leute, die den Blog von Dominik Comingsyl gelesen habe, es ist ja in vielen Stellen sehr.
So im Koren.
Also er schreibt die ganze Zeit dadrüber, wie er so die eigentlich die Weltpolitik neu ordnen will und äh.
Äh das funktionieren könnte im Falle ein
Nein, das hat er nicht. Das hat er nachhinein äh geschrieben und das wissen wir dann dem Whey Buckmaschinen, dass das dann für eine Lüge von von Coming
das macht euch ständig, er hat sein Twitter-Konto gelöscht, vor ein paar Jahren, hat mir vergessen, dass es Cashes gibt und wir haben alles dann so wieder auf die Beine gestellt, ey.
Was er ist, der hat einen enormen Selbstvertrauen,
und er ist sehr zielorientiert. Also das wussten wir, also der ist nicht wie viele Berater, er tut was heute populär ist. Das muss man ihm zugeben. Der Hart, immer ein Ziel im Kopf,
jahrelange arbeitete er in die gleiche Richtung und der um einfach dann dieses Ziel zu erreichen. Also das ist ein bisschen wie er anders ist als die meisten.
Aber, Jens haben wir gesehen, es ist nicht nur, dass er selbst ein Problem ist, wegen diese ganze Kassengeschichte.
Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr sicher, ob die Dominik Comings Methoden so gut funktionieren, weil.
Die ganze Partei hast ihm jetzt. Ja, also.
Also kurz mal nur das mal äh zusammengefasst zu haben,
im Kern, was passiert ist, er ist krank geworden, er hat gegen diese Auflagen, die Quarantäne auflagen verstoßen und das war deshalb so ein Aufschrei, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt sich eigentlich Großparteien komplett im Logdown befand, Leute dafür bestraft worden sind, wenn sie irgendwie das Haus verlassen haben.
Ja, ja, haben, können Freunde nicht sehen, könnte Familie nicht sehen.
Und er setzt sich ins Auto fährt vierhundertfünfzig Kilometer äh quer durchs Land mit seiner ganzen Fall mit seinem Sohn, noch mit äh an Bord,
äh mit dem Argument, ja, er müsse sich ja um Kinderbetreuung kümmern, das war ja auch noch so ein Ding, so, ja, weil er hätte ja keine bekommen, was vollkommen absurd ist.
Stimmt auch überhaupt nicht, ja.
Und dann, wenn er dann vor Ort ist in diesem Norden von England dann sich eben auch noch Ausflüge
leistet während er krank ist. Und das war so der Aufschrei und dann gab's eine Woche lang ein enormen Druck, wo ich mir gedachte so, oh, okay, äh jetzt.
Also die eigentlich komplett rechtslastig.
Die rechte, die so die die Bulle waren Zeitungen, die normalerweise für Johnson sind, waren gegen Comics, oder das war schon interessant.
Aber trotzdem hat Boris Johnson es nicht geschafft, äh da irgendeine Konsequenz zu ziehen, weil er weiß, dass er ihn nicht verlieren kann. Ich denke, wenn er ihn absägt, dann ist er halt auch komplett geliefert. Das ist dann auch das Ende von Boris Johnson.
Ja, oh oder hat ja keine Ahnung, was äh ähm ähm was es machen gibt. Ja. Äh äh er hat ohne Comics hat er kein Disziplin, ja,
ähm und aber das.
Das ist der Fall in Sachen Brexit. Das ist auch ein Grund, weil diese vorherige Diskussion. Warum Großbritannien diese Übergangsperiode nicht verlängern will? Das ist hundert Prozent Comings,
Ziel, wir setzen den Ziel, befinden wir dieses Ziel, zu fast jedem Preis so erreichen.
Aber Corone Virus ist anders, ja? Weil,
diese Dirigie, die das britische Volk in so zwei Gurten zu trennen, die,
in Sachen Brexit, das geht dann halt nicht. Also die Situation ist dann heutzutage eine ganz andere,
Ich nehme dann dieses Beispiel von ähm äh so eine Art äh Gutschein,
für ähm äh für Essen, für Kinder, arme Kinder, während diese Chorona Pandemie.
Also die Regierung hat eine besondere System, die sie dieser Gutscheinsystem,
Verfügung gestellt, für arme Familien, damit die dann zusätzliches Geld kriegen, für das Essen für Kinder während dieser Chrona Pandem,
Aber jetzt kommen die Sommerferien, also und dann,
offiziell endet dieses Programm jetzt Ende Juni. Also was bedeutet, dass Familien müssen dann weiterhin alles bezahlen für die, für das Essen, für die Kinder während diese Sommerperiode.
Diesel und normalerweise in Großbritannien, die Kinder dann kriegen das Essen in einem in ein Menzer in der Schule. Also ab September ist es dann wieder einfacher. Groben zusammenge.
Und dies war schon dann ein Problem, daher wie wir es dann weiternehmen in den Sommer dann weiter laufen, so es gab viele viele Diskussionen darüber auf Twitter und auch in den in den Medien.
Und dann am Sonntag kommt dann ein Brief heraus,
von Markus Rush wird, der ist ein ein Stürmer von Manchester United. Kommt aus einer sehr armen Familie, hat selbst von einem System selbst profitiert als Kind,
Und der hat dieses Brief an Dominan, sondern sich nicht einen Dominik. Kann man nicht sagen, dann Boris Johnson äh geschrieben. Es ist sehr wichtig für
arme Familien, wie meiner, das.
Kinder, ein Essen kriegen, jeden Tag, auch während den Sommerferien, also für da eine Vlängerung von ein paar Monaten für dieses und dieses Gutscheinsystem.
Am Montag auf eine Pressekonferenz sagte die britische Region. Nein, das tun wir nicht.
Und am Dienstag, die haben danke sagen. Nein, das tun wir dann doch. Und dann Boys Johnsing hat gesagt,
wichtig ist. Also das ist das erste, dass ich darauf und höre, ja,
Also, sorry, aber Markus Rassi, der ist ein bekannter so Fußballspieler, der des Landes, das ist wie, keine Ahnung, äh Leon Goretzke sagt, okay, äh ich setze mich für arme Kinder ein oder so, ja.
Ja.
Und dann die Regierung macht so eine komplette Drehung und tut was der Fußballspiele dann,
gefordert hat.
Gefordert hat, ja.
In diese in in wäre es komplett anders. Die ringen würde sagen, nee, also es ist sehr wichtig, dass
auch arme Menschen, wohne nicht an Staatshilfen, die den Mail wird so reagieren, nein, wir tun nicht aus Steuergelder, für diese Leute, die man einfach arbeiten oder sowas, um um um für für das Essen für die Kinder zu sagen,
und jetzt ist es komplett anders, aber dann,
auch und das ist ja auch interessant. Es herrschte Widerstand gegen Boris Johnson und der konservative Hinterbänkler.
Die warm sauer. Und die haben auch offen gesagt, nein, Moment, Mann, diese ist ein ernsthaftes Problem. Wir müssen anders agieren. Und dann.
Wir wissen ja nicht so komplett, aber ich bin fassiger. Dieses Problem,
kam weiß dann auf dem Schreibtisch und Dominik Comings am Montag erschienen. Dann sagt er, nein, warum machen wir, warum ändern wir unseren äh unsere Meinung zu so dieses Themenfeld
Weil das ist ja tippisch Comings. Sie strebigkeit, wir ändern unsere Positionen nicht,
und wir trennen das Gesellschaft in oder in zwei Gruppen. Wie trennt man das Gesellschaft in in zwei Gruppen in Sachen Korona,
alle sind betroffen, arm, reich, alle Regionen, Shortland, Wales, alle kennen Menschen, die einfach entweder gestorben sind oder kennen Leute, die.
Wo die können die die alte Eltern nicht besuchen oder sowas. Das hat das ganze Gesellschaft betroffen und wenn die Regierung dann den Eindruck gibt, okay, wir sind dann einfach gemein.
Das ist dann einfach nicht gut in die Kommunikation von der Regierung,
Und das bedeutet, den Grund warum vorher Coming sehr nützlich war für die Regierung.
Ist ja nicht so gut, wie er vorher war. Weil seine Methoden in Chone zeigen, funktionieren nicht also so, so gut. Wie wie die vorher in Sachen Brexit funktioniert haben,
Also das bedeutet, es ist nicht nur dank darum, dass er jetzt ein Problem geworden ist, ja? Weil er so gehasst ist und du kommst auch unter Konservativen, die geben ihm keine Information mehr,
Also das bedeutet, dass auch strategisch, es wäre klug, ihm zu feuern. Ähm aber das wird.
Johnson dann dann nicht tun. Aber hat enorm an Unterstützung, auch in konservativen Kreisen in letzter Zeit verloren. Und das könnte es dann sehr wichtig sein.
Jetzt gab's dann gleich noch eine Krise oben drauf mit der Black Lifes Wetter,
Bewegung, die natürlich in USA gestartet ist und dort auch immer noch äh sehr aktiv ist und die dann auf eine ganz interessante Art und Weise auf einmal in Großbritannien sich breit gemacht hat. Ich musste sehr schmunzeln, weil ich ja selber auch gerade äh ein halbes Jahr in Bristol gelebt habe, dass ausgerechnet
dort dann äh diese ja Statue von sind etwa.
Abgerissen wurde von Demonstranten ein paar paar hundert Meter weiter gerollt wurde und dort einfach in den Fluss geworfen wur,
Ich kannte die Gegend auch irgendwie ganz gut. Ja. Und dadurch,
Riss nochmal eine andere Debatte auf, die äh natürlich auch Großbritannien betrifft. Und gerade das Verhältnis von Großbritannien zu seiner Geschichte ist ja nochmal anders als in den USA.
Ist ist ja generell auch so ein Unterreflektierterbereich
Ja, also wir hatten, glaube ich, ganz zu Beginn, als wir mit dieser Serie angefangen haben, viel über diesen Journalisten gesp
prochen über das Selbstverständnis, irgendwie diesen Hang zu diesem Empire, so diese Sehnsucht nach nach äh nach einer Zeit, die irgendwie Größe äh und und und Weltmacht symbolisiert hat und ja, die sich manche Leute halt herbei wünschen und,
ist eben auch irgendwie mit Brexit äh.
Wollten. Und jetzt stürzen die Statuen und sogar kommt auf einmal mitten in die Diskussion rein, der ja.
Von Boris Johnson, das ist ja sein erklärtes Vorbild oder wer gern wie er, nicht, dass er irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise in der Nähe kommen würde. Was mich denn das jetzt nochmal mit rein in diese ganze Debatte.
Ja, also grob zusammengefasst, die.
Die haben nie so wirklich akzeptiert, dass die konolernieren Seiten komplett vorbei sind.
Ähm und das ist was man sieht, es gibt eine ein Teil der der Brexit befürworter die sind dann für.
So diese so Weltmacht, Großbritannien, also die haben auch dieses Spruch kommen, zwei Punkt null verwendet. Die reden von.
Handelsbeziehungen erneut mit Australien und Neuseeland und Kanada und so weiter. Also das bedeutet man muss auch sagen.
Kosten, so wie Roads und die anderen großen Figuren der der Kolonialzeiten. Die haben Ingrosbritannien.
Nicht nur schlimmen Sachen gemacht. Ja, also,
Es gibt viele Schulen in die Kosten gebaut hatte, zum Beispiel, oder? Oder ähm
Subventionen für Bridge Universitäten, die kommen von ähm zum Beispiel auch immer noch.
Aber es gab nie eine faire auseinandersetzung vom.
Was haben diese Menschen getan? Was was bedeutet das für den für den britischen Alltag.
Und das war auch dann natürlich auch ein ein verbreitetes Problem, während Brexit zeigen. Also, das bedeutet, dass, was ist Großbritanniensrolle? Was wahr Großbritanniens, also diese,
diese, was sind wir irgendwie? Das und Großbritannien führt so eine Debatte nach eine.
Sehr verrückter Art und Weise. Weil es gab ja eine Debatte, ob könnte man dieses Status in in,
im Brestel schon in Fern, das sind stattdessen in ein Museum äh Umlagern oder so, gab's ja schon dieses, die diese Debatte lauft es schon zehn Jahre lang. Wir haben keine Einigung gefunden,
Und dann, dann kam dann dazu, dann die Gegenproteste eine Woche danach.
Von so rechtsextremisten in London. Die wollen den den.
Verteidigen, aber der Londoner Bürgermeister hat so einen Metallmauer, um den den den den,
Curches Statue äh eingerichtet. Um dieses zu zu verteidigen gegen die Rechtsextremisten.
Und die haben so Heilhitlerzeichen gemacht. Vor dem Status von.
Geschlagen hatte, ja. Also vollkommen eine irre. Ähm aber weil am Ende und das ist dann die große Debatte. Also ist, weil.
Churchill war auch.
Rassistisch. Oft, ja, der war auch zum Teil antisemitisch. Ja, in seiner Karriere.
Aber irgendwie, ja, man, das ist alles hier eine graue Zone,
aus mal, ich bin selbst ja ich bin total zufrieden, dass die haben den großen Statue abgerissen
Aber ich finde, ist ein bisschen blöd, ein ein Church ist das abzureißen. Obwohl ich selbst Problemen habe mit dieser Ehre von Churchill und der war so der große Held der Großbritannien gerettet hat und so weiter,
Aber irgendwie, das ist alles ja grau, also es gibt ja keine kompletten Helden und keine,
oh ja, klar, die Leute, die nur Börse waren, ja, dass,
das gibt's dieses Jahr. Aber aber irgendwie dazwischen gibt's eine, es war eine große Grauzone. Und da braucht man eine gute Debatte
und start einfach dann
klug umzugehen, einfach mal, ich verstehe, ich verstehe, warum die dann die Leute im Bristan Problem in diese Statue haben
aber vielleicht wär's nicht den sinnvollsten Wehartenweise da voranzugehen oder so. Es war krass hart, sieh diese Leute sind inakzeptabel, die sind falsch, die sind
ähm äh die einfach mal die sind nicht Menschen irgendwie.
Ähm einfach mal wieder diese sowallartige Reaktion.
Ähnlich wie er auch in den USA, ne, mit anderen Vorzeichen, hm.
Und dann die Reaktion vor der Labour Partei war aus meiner Sicht durchaus der der hat gesagt okay ich verstehe warum.
Ist nicht so richtig war, dass dieses Status, es ist noch da gibt.
Es wäre mir Liebe, dass einfach hin ein Museum äh Rübe so lagen. Ich verstehe dieses.
Angst oder dass sie dort genervt sind und so, aber,
gegen ein Gesetz, dass du zerstören und Hunde zu nehmen, kann ich auf keinen Fall unterstützen,
also ich bin halt härter nicht wie so wird verwendet, aber ich bin für die Rechtsstaat, ja. Das fand ich vollkommen gemessen,
Ja, aber dann die Reaktion, dass Boris Johnson war krass kritischer gegenüber die Leute in Bristolas, gegen Leute, die die ähm so die Rechtsextremisten, eine Woche danach in in den London,
das ist ja interessant. Ja, welche Leute er unterstützen, welche nicht. Und es ist mal wieder versucht, dann die zu Gruppen zu bilden.
Aber er hat auch dazu vergessen, er vergessen, dass in die die Wahlkreise, die die konservativen gewonnen haben im,
im Dezember besonders die Not Englischen Industriestädten. Da gibt's eine Menge endliche Minderheiten.
Nicht besonders die so diese engen Verbindung haben mit den viele die besonders städten.
Vieler Leute, Südherkunft aus Südasien, ja, also nicht an einem direkten Bezug mit dem, aber schon mit dem britchen Kolonialseiten.
Also in der, vor alle.
In der Papa Pipakistan äh Banglade. Aber diese Leute, die da eigentlich waren für die Concervity, wählen,
Die sehen dann hey, Moment mal, also.
Sind diese Menschen einfach eigentlich auf unserer Seite oder nicht? Ja, also dass dass die Wählerschaft der nicht gesehen etwas diverse ist aus,
die Parteimitglieder, das könnte mittelfristig ein Problem sein für die Conceritiven. Ah ja, an den Wahlloonen.
Jetzt hast du ihn schon äh erwähnt, hier ähm ist der neue Vorsitzende der Leberpartei. Er wurde äh im April, glaube ich, äh, gewählt, als es schon so Einschränkungen gab. Ich glaube, da konnte auch dieser Parteitag nur so.
Ja, es war virtuell nur, ja. Und man kriegt nur per per Briefwahl äh wählen, ja, ähm.
Aber die Wahl war glaube ich relativ klar, also er hat seine ähm Mitbewerber da deutlich ausgestochen und ich hatte auch selber dann ein bisschen damit gerechnet, weil ich mir irgendwie mittlerweile gar nicht mehr vorstellen konnte, dass,
also es muss einfach mal jemand mal wieder auf die Bühne der
wie halbwegs einem den Glauben an die Menschheit zurückgibt und das scheint bei ihm so ein bisschen der Fall zu sein. Also er hat ein äh sehr staatstragendes, was ja eben auch schon ein bisschen beschrieben, ne, so äh,
ordentliches Auftreten äh ratet nicht rum und es irgendwie.
Sehr hohes.
Sehr ruhig, zivilisiertes Auftreten, aber hat auch was in der Bürde und äh hat irgendwie auch eine klare Liberale Position. Das war zumindest bisher so mein Eindruck, er gehörte ja schon mit auch in die Führungsriege, um herum
und war ja auch derjenige, glaube ich, der damals als über viel über den Brexit abgestimmt wurde und welche Position Leber einnehmen sollte
eher so äh diese Beschlüsse mit durchgesetzt hat, na ja, man sollte, war das jetzt mal ganz genau.
Davor zumindest für ein zweites Referendum,
der war der war einfach mal so, okay. Der der hat so dieses Kompromiss der Labelpartei verhandelt. Wir sind nicht gegen den Brexit, aber wir wollen ein sozial gerechtigeres Brexit
und weil dieses Deal kein sozial gerecht ihres Brexit ist, wollen wir dann ins zweites Referendum, so das war grob, was er.
Verhandelt hatte, ja. Ähm
ja, äh ich stimme dir vollkommen zu. Ähm seid ihr am Abend ist, also es gab enormen Plus äh in den Meinungsumfragen, dass der Prophylaster Label Partei, Vorsitzender, als Oppositionsführer, seid bla, ähm,
der hat einen echtfähigen Team, um sich äh so gesammelt, sehr kluge Menschen sehr fehlte Menschen. Ähm.
Er hat schon einige so Gewinne äh gehabt.
Besonders in ähm äh in Sachen die Kosten für Wiesen für.
Arbeitskräfte in der, zum Beispiel, weil Leute, die von außerhalb der EU kommen, brauchen ein Visum in Großbritannien, das kostet eine Menge,
und die haben diese Kosten dann für äh für NHS-Mitarbeiter dann gestrichen. Das war eine Idee der Label-Partei äh und das hat er dann durchgesetzt zum Beispiel,
ähm was erhält sich.
Ein bisschen manchmal aus dem politischen Alltag raus. Also in in Sachen Dominik Coming zum Beispiel hat er sehr wenig gesagt,
Hast du auch einfach gesagt, nee, also wir sehen, dass die Regierung hat für sich selbst ein Problem da gemacht. Wir hauen uns raus.
Wir wollen, wir wollen nicht, dass Woristonsen und sagt, ja, ihr seid nur gegen mein Berater, weil ihr seid Gegner, alles, was wir tun. Und vor den typischen Oppositionellen Spruch.
Ich hab ja ein bisschen Angst, das erhält sich so viel raus, dass manchmal.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus, was taktisches Spielerei.
Zum Beispiel. Wenn wir kommen zurück zu dem Brexit. Äh Diskussion.
Es ist ja klar, dass Großbritannien braucht eine Verlängerung der der Übergangsperiode.
Storme hat sich offiziell nicht zu diesem Themenfeld positioniert.
Weil er denkt, dass sowas wäre nicht populär und er sieht Kritik zu sich.
Wenn er das sagt, ja, dass die Konzerte, wenn dann mal sagen, ha ja, tippe ich,
ist stamme, sie waren schon immer gegen Brexit, sie akzeptieren, das das Willen des Britchen, Volkes, das ist im einzigen Grund, warum sie das jetzt sagen.
Aber natürlich um wirklich die ernsthaften Problemen des Landes zu verstehen oder so akzeptieren. Und das britsche wirtschaft, braucht mehr Zeit.
Wäre es an meinem, aus meiner Meinung sinnvoll für eine Verlängerung der der übrigens Periode einzusetzen,
Ich verstehe irgendwie, weil wo man es sich raushält, aber ich unterstütze die Position von Stamme nicht hundert Prozent. Ich find's ein bisschen schwach.
Ich habe so ein bisschen ein paar Kommentatoren äh gelesen und gehört, die so.
Die das so interpretiert haben, dass er auch versteht, dass die Regierung hier von ihrem Weg auch nicht abzubringen ist, durch diesen Druck,
dass das sozusagen etwas ist, was einfach passieren wird und,
dass er sich stattdessen dann einfach und so macht er das, glaube ich, auch bei diesen Befragungen, das hast du schon erwähnt, diese Primelisters Crash ist so ein regelmäßig stattfindendes Frage Antwortspiel, da hat die Opposition das Recht so und so viel Fragen zustellen
der Fraktionsgröße, was er dort auch macht ist so, er.
Er bringt die Fälle vor, die klar belegbar sind, äh er bezieht sich nur auf die Aussagen der Regierung und hält sie ihnen dann selber vor. Sagt hier, guck mal, ihr habt gesagt, ihr wollt das machen, warum habt ihr das nicht getan? Wo man ja nichts.
Wirklich in entgegnen kann
Wenn man immer nur sagt, ich will aber gerne das, ja, dann ist es ist eine andere Verhandlungsposition und an dieser Stelle denke ich, baut er sozusagen den Käse auf, dass ein Ende des Jahres äh der Regierung sein wird, so ihr habt gesagt, ihr habt einen Deal
Ihr wolltet die ganze Zeit einen Deal.
Wo ist der Deal? So und es kommt kein Deal und dass er daraus eben das Momentum aufbauen möchte, um dann letzten Endes auch wenn sich alles andere nicht mehr verhindern lässt, äh läber wieder an die Regierung zu führen.
Ja, aber das ist dann vielleicht dann konkreten Einzelpunkten finden, wo man dann den Druck erhören kann,
ähm und und wird dann mal sehen, in den nächsten Monaten, wo diese Punkte singt und wie man dann dieses Druck dann erhören kann. Weil natürlich also dann das das ist droht, also dann.
Bekommen dann zurück, so Brexit, ist dann Großbritanniens wirtschaftliche Krise ist schon.
Sehr, sehr schlecht, also den den Verlust der Brutinanzprodukt, die es doppelt so hoch wie in Deutschland.
Dann kommt dann Brexit dann hinzu.
Köln wäre es möglich, dass eine eine zweite Welle in Großbritannien gewinnt, äh beginnt,
wenn sowas dann Koronevirus Welle beginnt ist Großbritannien überhaupt in der Lage zurück zu einem zu gehen.
Es gibt Große dann große ernsthafte Fragen. Es ist auch sehr wichtig, dass den wahren Verkehr,
Frei war's, zwischen die EU und Großbritannien, während die komplette Korone Virus. Es gab eine Ausnahme für Lastenfahrer, zum Beispiel für Corantine, bei der Hinreise und Ausreise
ähm äh aus Großbritannien.
Wenn man fügt dann hinzu, Anfang Januar nächstes Jahr, Zollkontrollen. Ja, also die mögliche Reduzierung der eine ausreisen durch zum Beispiel,
wenn die Regierung überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist, die konkreten Maßnahmen.
Ähm Süßen stimmen oder einzurichten für ein Notel Brexit.
Weil ich muss dann sagen, also die Liste von den noch aufstehenden Problemen ist enorm.
Und die Positionen von beiden Seiten sind noch sehr sehr weiter auseinander. Und Boris Johnson nimmt dieses Problematikdate jetzt ein Stand der Brexit-Handlung überhaupt nicht. Danke Saal, der hat einen Anruf mit Fondaleyen, mit Schau Michelle.
Und mit Sasoli, der der Vorsitzende des Europäischen Parlamentes im am Montag. Da geht's halt wird ein bisschen mehr um, so ein bisschen mehr Schwung und innerhalb von sechs Monaten, sechs Wochen.
Wir können sogar den Rahmen von einem Deal finden, ja? Es ist,
vollkommen absurd, also niemand in Brüssel glaubt, dass dass irgendeine Lösung in Hart von fünf, fünf Wochen möglich ist.
Auf die Liste steht. Fischerei Politik, ja? Es ist nur eine Kleinigkeit, aber es sehr sehr wichtig.
Aber auch für die EU eigentlich.
Für die EU auch für manche Länder, aber es ist nur null Komma zwei Prozent des Bruttoinland Produkts in Großbritannien, ja? Es ist nicht.
Also das ist so Wettbewerbsgleichheit. Also das ist enorm wichtig. Also das bedeutet, dass für die Waren, die Großbritannien produziert, ja, auch Agrarprodukten, sondern auch Autos,
Farmeprodukte. Die Herstellungs,
äh äh Systeme darf. Britischer, da darf die Umweltstandards geringe sein in Großbritannien. Darf die Arbeitestandards, dieser Abend an von Sachen.
Noch dazu kommt dann staatliche Beihilfe für britischen Unternehmen. Ja, also kein Großbritannien, dann enormen Subventionen geben, zu förmen, um zu sagen, hey, Moment mal.
Du kriegst irgendeine enorme Subvention, um um ein Fabrik hier zu bauen, statt irgendwo anders in der EU. Und das ist natürlich deutlich gefährlicher für die EU, in Vergleichsrelage mit.
Kanne da oder so. So, ja. Es ist nicht so hilfreich. Volkswagen kann nicht so einfacher, eine Auto in in Thronto produzieren und dann das nach Europa exportieren. Es ist nicht, es macht keinen Sinn,
aber dann,
wenn Großbritannien gibt, nie Sahne, eine enorme Subvention, weiterhin in Großbritannien zu produzieren, dann die EU-Wettern sagen, okay, Moment mal, dann heben wir dann ein höhere Zölle auf auf Importe von Britchenauto.
Dann geht's dann den schlichtungsverfahren System, also das bedeutet, wenn wenn Großbritannien trägt aus und dann so ein Problem dann auftaucht, ja, dann Windgruße tanzen, gibt eine Vention, ja, für für sowas.
Und da geht's halt ähm ähm wie lös man so im System. Und auch die EU blickt in den Choronovirus äh Situationen in Großbritannien und halt das schon Angst.
Es herrscht jetzt gerade ein Skandal in Großetanien. Mein Firma ist heißt Pest Fix,
Ja, so das war so an Firma, ähm die ist normalerweise in so die Kontrolle von so, äh keine Ahnung, Bienenraten äh die kommen dann zu Hause, um um Braten zu entfernen. So, ja.
Es war eine super kleine Firma, die haben einen Vertrag von über hundert Millionen Pfunden gekriegt für die Lieferung von Schutzmasken zu Korona.
Die Regierung hat dieses dieses Vertrag gegeben, an dem gleichen Tag, wie die Ausschreibung ähm veröffentlicht haben,
und Großbritannien muss die Systemen für öffentlichen Ausschreibungen
noch einhalten, bis Ende der, der Übergangsperiode. Also das bedeutet, dass die keinen Fall, EU Rest, denn dieses in diese Situation eingehalten
Es gab sechzehntausend Firmen, die sich für dieses Vertrag beworben haben. Aber die haben dieses.
Dieses Vertrag in so einer Testen Kontrollefirma,
schon abgegeben, obwohl diese Firma gar kein ähm Hintergrund hatte, in die Lieferung von Schutzmasken,
Also das bedeutet, das ist ein Zeichen von wie öffentlichen Ausschreibungen, dann in der zukünftigen Großbritannien dann laufen könnte.
Dann es gibt auch dann hinzu, dann dazu, die das Ganze Themengebiet, Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik, da steht in die politische Deckdeklaration, dass Großbritannien will einen engen,
Zusammenarbeit mit Großbritannien in die in dieses Themenbereich. Und das lehnen die Briten jetzt ab. Also die EU sagt, okay, wir wollen dieses die Verhandlungen dieses Thema im Bereich jetzt öffnen und sagt, nein,
Und sowas macht dann auch und der Altersmarkt dann auch Angst. Und in Großbritannien und auch dazu,
Tweese May, er wird verstanden, die Datenbanken besonders besonders gegen Kriminellen,
in der EU sind auch für Großbritannien auch in den Nachtbrexit Zeitnutzlich. Und jetzt die jetzige Regierung san nie, also wir wollen da keine kann es zusammenarbeiten.
Also das bedeutet, das es gibt die Reihe von Problemen und ich habe auch dann nur die Irland, sogar nicht erwähnt. Weil da gibt's auch keine Klarheit in sich. Weil,
vor dem Ende in dem Wahlkampf geantwortet zu dieser Frage. Wird es Soul-Kontrollen und sogenannten Importdeklarationen, ja? Soll es eine Art
Formular, die man ausfüllen muss, äh um zu gucken, was habe ich in diese, die in den Dingen gegen dieses Container, wie viele gibt's hier, der hier dabei.
Muss ein Not irisches Firma sowas ausfühlen.
Bei ein Export von Waren aus Nordirland und die Einlieferung in England wäre es oder Schottland. Nein, hat er gesagt. Ja? Seitdem hat die Regierung exitiert, ja, das muss man tun.
Nicht nur, dass er das äh gesagt hat von Anfang an als,
Theresa Mey äh sozusagen in der Situation war, das zu akzeptieren, war das so einer der Hauptgründe, warum sie gegen sie gefeuert haben. Und dann hat er auf diesen letzten Metern halt dieses Abkommen mit der EU gemacht, damit er irgendwie seinen Brexit-Tag durchbekommt.
Ata gesagt, okay, dann machen wir das.
Ist mir scheißegal.
Und danach noch behauptet, das wäre nicht so und jetzt mussten sie jetzt das erste Mal wieder.
Und es ist jetzt so, ja? Und dann Leute, der Premierminister hat eine, hat uns gesagt, das wären nicht der Fall. Aller Experten haben genau den Gegenteil gesagt, ja? Und wir hatten Rechner nicht. Ähm.
Und dann grob, also der hat etwas getan, was was niemand getan hat, die mir seit Jahrzehnten, da hat fast alle notierischen Politiker in diesem Brexit Fragen vereint.
Alle Parteien, die nur die Land sind gegen den Brexity.
Und unter der zerstört. Die Verbindungen zwischen oder auch in so in den Reaktionen zu Kohlevirus. Da hat versucht so eine Art,
kollabratives System zwischen und und das,
das ist alles abgebrochen in den, in den letzten Wochen. Also, das bedeutet,
die Regierung nimmt keine von diese Problemfällen überhaupt ernst.
Und die, die sagen, wir wollen keine Verlängerung, wir sind nicht in der Lage, Zollkontrolle, Kontrollen selbst machen,
wir wollen unser Kontrolle wieder übernehmen im Bereich der Fischerei Politik. Aber da gibt's auch Problemen. Weil was für Fische es gibt in den Britschen Gewässer, ist nicht fast die britischen, die Briten essen, ja? Ich war letzte Woche auf,
auf Sylt. Und da gibt's eine enorme Bearbeitungsfabrik. Wovon kommen die Heringer, auf die ihr diese in dieses Fabrik in der auf Sylt, ja, die kommen aus Großbritannien,
weil das ist wo die Heringe sind, aber die bringen essen keine Heringen, die essen ähm ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt, habt ihr euch das auf Deutsch? Cabayo, ist der kann das sein?
Kann man ja also. Ähm und.
Für Fisch und Chips.
Ja genau, genau. Und das bedeutet, dass was für Fische die Briten haben, im Bridges Gewässer. Ist nicht, was die Briten konsumieren, ja? Also
und und das Ganze die ganze Heringe werden nach Deutschland exportiert in diesem riesen Fabrik im beiarbeitet,
oder im Bereich der Datenaustausch zum Beispiel, auch Equipmenz im Bereich der der Datenschutzgrundverordnung haben die Briten auch nie auch nicht geregelt,
ja? Und dann kamen heut kam heute Vormittag stark sein, dass die bereiten ein riesen Werbekampagne für den kommenden äh Monaten vor. Das.
Unternehmen müssen sich für ein No Deal Brexit vorbereiten,
wie können Firmen auf ein No Deal Brexit vorbereiten? Weil die haben keine Ahnung wie sehr den juristischen Rahmen auf der britische Seite aus, ja,
bin ich ein denken wir daran, dass das dein Podcast unternehmen, nicht den Berliner, ansässiges, sondern in,
sind aus Frankreich,
und und die brauchen dann einen Arm zu wissen, was machst du mit meinem, meinem privaten Daten? Wie liefen wir das? Meine Model über Abstorze in anderen Länder oder sowas,
Großbritannien hat gar nicht begonnen diese Dinge zu regeln.
Und wie könnte ich aus Unternehmers digitales Unternehmer überhaupt wissen
wie funktionieren diese Sachen? Also, das habe ich heute Vormittag auf Training populisiert. Also, ja, versucht doch mal mit einer eine so eine Werbekampagne. Aber wenn ich kein Klarheit habe, wie ich agieren kann, weil die juristischen Rahmen in Großbritannien nicht exist
ja? Wie kann ich als Firma.
Agieren, ja? Es bleibt mir gar nichts anderes so übrig, aus meinen Firmen zu schließen, ja, im Befleisch in manchen Fernsehen. Und kommt das Antwort dazu? Ja, ihr habt das Firmen schon vier Jahre nur Moment No Dial vorzubereiten, ja?
Boys Johnson hat das gesagt, im November, ja, hier, äh, ja, Herr Deal, es ist hier bereit.
Niemand hat sich auf No Deal vorbereitet, vier Jahre lang. Und das ist einfach mal, dass die haben nur Ahnung, was die wollen, die haben keinen Plan und es ist jetzt einfacher mal.
Die Verantwortung auf anderen zu verlagen, als dann nach einem viel genannten Weise ähm äh ernsthaften Vorbereitungen vorzunehmen.
Ähm also ich hab.
Durch die diese ganze Brexit-Situation es gab ja immer.
Ein bisschen Hoffnung. Ja.
Man hatte, man hatte bis den Unterhauswahl in die Semmel irgendwie gehofft, ja könnte es doch klappen, dass jemand, dass man irgendwie verlieren.
Und dann seitdem gab's dann die Option. Okay.
Man hat zumindest die Zeit etwas zu verhandeln, besendet dieses Jahres. Dann kommt Karone Weiris Eviros hinzu,
und alle haben so beginnen so gedacht, okay Moment mal, diese Krise ist so schlimm für Großbritannien, dass dann Großbritannien könnte, sie mindest ein bisschen mehr Zeit brauchen,
um sich von die schlimmsten Auswirkungen von diese Situation zu retten. Hat ein große Tanja, auch dann, das dann auch nicht getan.
Also, das bedeutet, was ist dann dem Weg aus diese Krise jetzt in Großbritannien? Ja. Es ist.
Es ist ja kaum zu glauben. Also die die das britische, ja.
Die waren durch den ganzen Brexit. So vollkommen schwach. Ja,
Wir wollen, wir sind pro EU, aber da mischen sie. Wir mischen uns in den in dieses Referendumdebatte nicht ein
weil manche von unsere Kunden sind gegen gegen die EU und so, die wir haben uns raus. Ja, wir wollen Sanfenberg sind, auch Scheiße, wir kriegen Transantenbrexit. Oh, wir wollen ein Brexit mit einem Deal, okay, okay, verakzeptieren ein Brexit.
Irgendein Breakseit, aber es muss mit einem Deal sein. Ja, auch die CIBI ist jetzt sauer. Also, es aber.
Also Sivi ist die.
Ähm.
Also Industrie.
So ein Industriedachverband, ja. Ähm und man muss dann die Frage stellen.
Wie wird dann die britische Staat und des britische System? Nach diese zwei Krisen dann aussehen.
Man hat den Britschen Staat so in Hüll, so so schwach gemacht. Ähm das.
Das wie ist Großbritannien dann überhaupt in der Lage.
Wenn nimmt Großbritannien dann jetzt ernst. Ja, ist so Frankreicher zum Beispiel, die Grenzen geöffnet zu alle europäische Länder, außer die Briten.
Das ist katastrophal. Ja. Oh und oder und.
Oder oder dieses Testing ab, in Kohle wirst, ja, wären wir ein. Das Ding funktioniert ja überhaupt nicht, ja. Ist.
Es ist ja aber dann.
Oder oder dieses die, die haben, die haben so ein, ein digitales, das alte Digitalsystem, was überhaupt funktioniert, hat er. Weil diese virtual Voting-System für das Britche Unterhaus, ja. Die Abgeordneten können zu Hause sitzen und von da aus äh wählen,
die waren grob damit zufrieden, die Abgeordneten.
Und dann, es war dann einen Nachteil für Boris Johnson, weil fünfzig Abgeordnete durften gleichzeitig in London sein und den Press mussten zu Hause bleiben.
Und zwar, dass ein Nachteil, weil er brauchte diese soll hinter ihm,
und denn die haben dann einen Plan entwickelt, das ja, man man man könnte mit soziale Distanzierung doch noch abstimmen, ja
und die haben das den benannt, ja? Die haben so dann eine eine Schlange
ein Kilometer lang, so um den Parlamentsgebäuden, damit dann die die Abgeordneten überhaupt abstimmen können, weil es gibt kein schriftliches oder elektronisches Abstimmungsverfahren
in Westminster. Nur so eines jedes, jede Abstimmung so eine Hammelsport,
und die die sahen dann wie Schafe, ja? Also eine Linie
um und die haben das dann morgen benannt,
So, der Fraktionsvorsitzende Idee eingeleitet hatte und Kongre, dass sie so diese verrückte, langen Tanz, die man die in die man tut, in denen so eine in eine Linie.
Und aber ehrlich, also die fast Großbritannien jetzt braucht, ist.
Einige halbwegs fähige.
Sagen wir normaler Politiker. Ja, diese Regierung ist unglaublich schwach.
Und zur Zeit überhaupt nicht in der Lage.
Sachen so organisieren. Ja, verklarheitssorgen.
Die das britische Bewölkung so beruhigen. Ja, das und dann es ist.
Nicht oder was sind die Optionen für die kommenden Monaten in Sachen Brexit? Entweder die.
Es kommt dann No Deal, also dann komplette K. Ähm am ersten Januar,
und vielleicht sogar Keros vor dem ersten Januar, wenn alle Leute wissen, nie, dass das die kriegen kein kein Zutaten für Christmas Pudding nicht, oder so.
Ähm oder die Briten knicken komplett ein, ja, die akzeptieren,
was die EU sagt, ja und sagen, hey, Moment mal, so, es war uns am wichtigsten.
Pünktlich auszutreten oder man findet irgendeine Übergang Süden übergangen irgendwie
ja, dass man entscheidend, man trifft an Entscheidungen, dass man entscheidet, fast nichts
und man findet irgendein Weg, man baut eine ständige Großbritannine EU-Ausschuss irgendwie auf und damit löst man den restlichen Problemen,
Ja, ist aber falsch. Irgendwie.
Die sind die drei Optionen, die die zur Zeit auf dem Tisch sind. Ja, äh aber so seid alles zur Zeit geht in Richtung No Deal, aber wir waren schon hier in so einer Situation, ja? Vor,
Genau fast genau einem Jahr, als Johnson,
äh zuerst im Amt äh gekommen ist. Der leitete vollkommen in so eine No Deal Richtung und dann unter Zeitdruck.
Knickte er ein. Ja, besonders in Sachen Notierland. Es könnte das gleiche diesmal.
Ja, aber da war das Parlament natürlich auch noch eine andere. So, jetzt sind's halt äh also bei den Torys äh wirklich, hat man so den Eindruck nur noch so Ja-Sager, die
äh von Johnson ausgewählt wurden, wo halt auch relativ wenig Kompetenz äh am Start zu sein scheint. Das heißt, das Parlament ist nicht mehr das Parlament. Ich meine, als wir hier,
angefangen haben, dann äh hat sich sagen wir mal noch die vollständige Tradition
irgendwo noch abgebildet und es war voraussehbar, dass diese Widerstände aufkommen werden und die haben sich ja dann auch abgespielt, aber durch
die relativ schlechte Strategie von Corbyn, die Schwäche von Leberdaten damit ausgelöst hat und dann eben diese Niederlage in den Wahlen war es dann halt irgendwie auch damit vorbei. Und dadurch, dass ich
die Tore ist ausgerechnet auf so ein ja den Hauptpopulisten eingeschossen haben, weil sie der Meinung waren, wir brauchen jetzt einfach nur einen, der irgendwie dummes Zeug äh äh erzählt und die Sache irgendwie verkauft. Und wir machen das dann so in den Hintergrund. Im Prinzip ist das ja so
Trump ist im im europäischen Gewand
Dadurch haben sie sich natürlich dann und das sieht man auch in der Trump-Regierung vollständig ihrer eigenen Kompetenz entledigt und sind jetzt nicht mehr in der Lage auf die anderen Veränderungen, die halt zwangsläufig immer kommen, zu reagieren
Von daher sieht es mit meiner Meinung nach sehr nach einem No Deal aus. Und das ist eine Katastrophe und ich frage mich natürlich, es kann ja jetzt nicht sein,
dass es überhaupt niemanden gibt, der noch so ein bisschen Intelligenz am Start hat. Sprich, man könnte auch formulieren.
Irgendjemand hat ein Interesse an dieser Situation. Jetzt gibt's halt diese Sager des äh Desaster Kapitalismus sozusagen, wir fahren mal alles ordentlich gegen die Wand
danach äh äh liegt alles in Scherben, dann kann man das, was da ist, schön billig äh kaufen
und irgendwann wird's ja auch wieder besser und bis dahin geht's uns schon gut, weil wir haben sowieso Geld äh und der Rest ist uns so ein bisschen egal. Ist das eine Verschwörungstheorie an der Stelle oder.
Sickert das schon irgendwo raus.
Es ist mehr als eine Verschwörungstheorie. Ähm.
Sowas ist möglich, dass sowas schreibt oder motiviert Dominik Comings.
Ähm weil er will durch die Strukturen des britischen Staates komplett erneuern, sollte er, aber.
Nicht nach normalen Arten und Weisen. Das zu erneuern. Ich bin.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob die meisten Konzerte einfach so denken. Ja? Ähm die meisten konservativen haben einen.
Nach hinten blickenden Motivation für Brexit, nicht nach einem nach vorne blickenden, einfach mal.
Wir wollen so die nicht. Wir wollen ein Singapur on Temps oder so, ja. Ähm.
Ich denke auch, dass die viele Leute sagen Großbritannien gerade,
die jetzige Situation, also auf drohenden No Deal, Platz Krone Virus,
und die die diese super schlechte Reaktion der Regierung ist wie Black Wanne John Majore, also als ähm als Großbritannisch sturz der Mitte der Neunziger aus der, also diese so,
Euro Vorgängesystem.
Und das war dann von nicht von einem Tag bis die nächsten, aber in eine sehr kurze Periode von ein paar Monaten.
Da war das so dieses Ruf, dass diese Regierung herbwickt. Fähig war.
Ist dann in verschwunden und kam nie wieder.
Und das ist an dem Angst für die Konservitiven, dass obwohl die haben ein großes, einen großen Mehrheit.
Dann es ist ja dann alles verloren bei den nächsten und Hauswahl. Das bedeutet, dass dieses dass die die haben kein Weg sich wirtschaftlich zu retten.
Und die haben auch kein Ruf, weil die Wähler sagen, die Regierung war sie mindest Teil schuldig für diese Problemen. Ja, es ist nur.
Genug oder oder möglich, wenn man alles zerstört, dass die dass das Bewölkung denkt, anderen sind irgendwie schuldig.
Und der Virus natürlich auch.
Virus zum Teil, ja. Aber dann, es gibt an Mehrheit der Briten, die sagen, ja, wir sind für eine Verlängerung der Übergangsprojektübergangsperiode. Es gibt auch,
einen Klarmehrheit, der Brexit befürwortet, Iso, die, die eine Verlängerung sind. Also das bedeutet, dass diese Idee, dass.
Die Situation hat sich geändert, also dass man das Brexit ist nicht mehr Priorität Nummer eins,
das Wohlhaben, der bewirkerung und dass die Leute gesund bleiben und dass es britische Wirtschaft irgendwie halbwegs wirkt in den Interessen von viele Menschen,
das sind die Prioritäten, zur Zeit, innerhalb der Britsche Bewölkerung. Und das ist dann ein Grund, warum.
Das einfach mal immer noch den gleichen Kurs, also immer noch den, den den den Coming Skur ist, ich bin nicht sicher, ob das vollkommen wirkt.
Ja. Vielleicht wird's dann ausreichend sein, um no Deal zu kriegen, Ende des Jahres.
Aber ich bin jetzt überzeugt, dass wenn das der Lah der Situation ist, die haben keinerlei Chance.
Die den Unterhaus war, zwanzig, vierundzwanzig Sekunden. Ich wette sogar darauf, dass Boris Johnson überlebt, diese vier Jahren.
Dass die konservativen irgendwann mal wir haben auch gehört der ist selbst sehr unzufrieden mit den jetzt in Lage, es macht ja keinen Spaß, weil ein Land durch eine eine Krise zu bringen.
Er muss so viel arbeiten, was er nicht er mag das einfach nicht.
Er ist Gesundheitlich, es geht ihm gesundheitlich nicht gut, ja, seid Chola.
Hat so gesagt, dass er er braucht jetzt, er muss jetzt eine Brille tragen, zum Beispiel, weil weil er kann nur so schlecht sehen, seit er im im Krankenhaus war. Wir wissen, ich glaube, dass der die Wahrheit ist. Aber irgendwie.
Es macht keinen Spaß. Also das bedeutet kann er.
Er kann vielleicht ein überleben, ohne er sich im Arm bis Ende des Jahres. Aber wenn Panik ausbricht in Großbritannien, im Dezember, ja,
Es wäre aus meine Sicht nicht erstaunlich, wann die Konstellativ sagen, hey, Moment mal, das reicht uns jetzt.
Wir mögen Liebe, zumindest Jemand, der den Eindruck gibt, dass er hauptwegs fähig ist. Zum Beispiel der Finanzminister.
Wäre mein Tipp aus Nachfolge.
Was ist denn jetzt mit Schottland?
Ja, also.
Schottland hatte Problemen werden diese Krise, also die haben die Zahlen in ein bisschen weniger Schlimmmaß in in England, aber nicht unbedingt.
Äh die die der Chief Medical Office medizinische Beamte musste das ähnliche Skandal,
Es gibt ja Pluspunkte in den Meinungsumfragen für die immer unabhängigkeit,
Es gibt den ähm schossischen Parlamentswahl Mai nächstes Jahr.
Also super stark, num ähm ähm äh Umfrage werden für die schottischen Nationalisten.
Die können vielleicht sogar alleine die Regierung bilden. Ja, also.
Ja, das alles für zu eins zweites, unanipänglich geiles Referendum, irgendwann mal, ja. Und die Gesellschaftliche.
Reaktionen oder sage ich mal dieses Zusammenhang zwischen politischen Entscheidungen und die gesellschaftlichen Reaktionen,
waren in Shortland deutlich besser, also dieses Problem, Problem mit den Armen, Kindern, die wir vork vor Kürzen besprochen haben,
das hatten die, die die Schotten und Divalise schon gelöst. Ja, es war die dieses,
äh dieses Brief von den Fußballspielern war nur in England relevant, weil Wales und und Schottland hatte schon ein System entwickelt, um um um dieses Problem zu beheben. Also ja, also ähm ich denke, die sind ja,
vorkommen so in Richtung ein zweites Unabhängigkeitsreferent. Es gibt natürlich, es wird das, das Herr nur mittelfristig, es wird zwei Jahren brauchen, so,
denke, dass dass er alle frühesten, zwanzig, zweiundzwanzig, weiß sogar später.
Äh und man brauche die Zustimmung longs und sowas überhaupt zu organisieren. Wenn.
Wenn Stergin und ISMP dieses Gewalt gewinnen und Boris Johnson sagt, hey, nur, hey, wir will wir lehnen, so ein zweites äh Abstimmung ab.
Ja das könnte voll heftig sein. Ja. Äh man könnte dann so eine, ja Situation wie in Kaslonien erreichen. So ähm ein riesengroßen Protesten auf den Straßen so.
Aber Störchen ist klug, die Situation in Schortland ist zur Zeit ruhig,
sie will auf keinen Fall, dass es einen riesen Protesten gibt oder so zur Zeit, weil ich will sagen, ja, okay, wir wir können einem Mindesthamperabstand halten, wir wollen keinen riesen Protest oder so gerade. Ähm aber,
ja, das ist äh ein großes Sturm auf dem Horizont für für Jones.
Und die Situation in Nordirland. Ich meine äh es war so ein bisschen mein Eindruck, dass.
Die Bewältigung der Corona Krise dann schon im Wesentlichen eine Frage von Irland und Nordirland äh,
einigen sich hier auf entsprechende Maßnahmen war, als das in irgendeiner Form, die britische Regierung hier eine Rolle gespielt hätte.
Und ein Freund von mir der hat sich mir gesagt.
Ich mag sehr sehr gerne hier, aber fürs erste Mal bin ich zufrieden, politisch, dass ich in Nordirland bin. Ha, hat er mir gesagt, weil nur Eland, Gesundheit ist, kamen, sprechen, gut durch die Krise,
Also die Anzahl und weil normalerweise die die die ärmsten Betroffenen Städte und Regionen, Großbritannien, Regionen sind am härtesten betroffen,
Ja und Nordirland ist vielleicht, weil sie sehr arm. Durch die Krise aus dem Britchen durchschnitt.
Aber Irland war ja an sich auch ganz betroffen.
Ganz gut. Ja, etwa betroffen, aber hat schnell und hart reagiert. Also,
Irland hat alles schneller im Kräftiger ist,
aus Großbritannien, ja? Und die Reaktion, die Gesundheitliche Reaktion in ähm in Nordirland war ähnliche, als die Situation in die nierischen Republik, aus die Situation in in England.
Stimmt das nicht so in den Statistiken.
Ja, also Irland hatte auch viele Tote so, ne? Und äh, wenn man das jetzt auf die Bevölkerungszahl hochrechnet, befinden die sich halt eher so da, wo äh die USA gerade ist, wo beiden USA geht's halt ähm.
Geht es immer noch äh bergauf. So, also da ist das Problem noch nicht gelöst, aber man sieht halt, dass es äh in Großbritannien ist, ist es halt einfach auch noch nicht unter Kontrolle. Also
ist einfach, das läuft äh auf dem hohen Niveau äh äh weiter und ist halt äh wirklich schlimm. Irland ist so ein bisschen über dem Durchschnitt, der Europäischen Union, aber äh scheint sich da zumindest so ein bisschen zu fangen
Ähm was sicherlich vielleicht auch einfach mit der Nähe eben mit.
Mit mit Großbritannien einfach zu tun hat so, ne? Ähm na ja, trotzdem könnte es natürlich auch diese ganze.
Stimmung beeinflussen, das hat man ja hier schon ein paar Mal äh ob denn nicht Nordirland, am Ende,
in einem Gesamtirland besser davon käme, aus dieser gesamt Situation.
Aber diese, die Situation grade ist. Wir Brexit hat oder den, den Johnson Brexit Variante.
Hat,
für irgendeine Art Einigkeit in Nordirland gesorgt. Und Kohone Virus auch gegen diesem Teil, ja? Irgendwie,
wir sind irgendwie noch Menschen hier, wir müssen alle Menschen irgendwie halbwegs so, dass alle bleiben gesund.
Kann diese, so,
kompromissartige Situation so ein Verbleiben in nur Ehren, das weiß ich ja nicht. Aber die Situation ist zur Zeit, ja, in Not Irland entsprechend ruhig, ja,
können wir nicht sagen, in drei Monaten, sechs Monaten, wenn Krone Virus vorbei ist, vielleicht ist es dann anders. Aber zurzeit ist es entsprechend Ruhe.
Bleibt noch der Blick auf die EU. Ich meine, hast du den Eindruck, dass die Europäische Union jetzt Großbritannien, also im Prinzip schon abgeschrieben hat.
Also grob. Die EU, die EU hält zusammen, die aus in diese Streit um Fischereipolitiker, sowas die EU hier unbedingt will, ist.
Ist heutzutage klar. Die EU kommt auch mit Zollkontrollen. Grundsätzlich klar, die EU hat immer verstanden.
Ein Notierbrexit schädigt, die schädigt Großbritannien deutlich mehr Assist die EU-Schädig. Ich denke, das.
Und auch zum Beispiel von der vor ein paar Tagen gesagt gesagt hatte.
Wir brauchen ein gesamtes Schlichtungsverfahrenssystem, diese ganze Brexit-Situation.
Weil ohne sowas kann die Zukunftsbeziehung nicht funktionieren. Ja, es ist ein Dance von den großen größten Problemen mit mit der Schweiz. Ist das, es gibt keine einheitliche, schlichtungssystem.
Und dann und dieses Problem will die EU dann einfach vermeiden. Aber nicht zu jedem Preis. Also wenn Großbritannien das nicht akzeptiert, wäre die EU bereit mit ein No Deal,
zu leben. Ja, weil die die EU ist nicht nur stärker, sondern besser darauf vorbereitet.
Also ja, es wäre natürlich schade für die EU, aber die EU kann's sowas deutlich besser überleben, dass Großbritannien gerade. Ähm ja, ähm.
Ja, die EU wird alles tun, um doch noch ein Deal zu kriegen
aber nie zu jedem Preis und nicht unbedingt bis Ende des Jahres. Also
es gibt ja mehr Zeit, also Bahn je hat so gesagt, also wir denken, wir brauchen mehr Zeit. Wir haben, es gibt so viele Sachen, Sachen und Fragen, die die noch offen sind. Also, am liebsten mehr Zeit als raus ohne Deal, hat Bahn je klar gesagt, niemals,
und das, das wollen die Briten nicht höher. Also und die aber die EU ist ja bereit. Ähm oder mit möglichst berei.
Aber selbst zwei Jahre sind ja nun zum Aushandeln eines Handelsvertrages.
Das ist auch sehr wenig.
Quasi nichts. Also es ist ja äh, wenn, wenn das überhaupt irgendeinen Deal gibt und ich würde mal vermuten, irgendein Stück Papier, wo irgendwas trausch,
wird's schon irgendwie geben, ja, aber viel
steht da nicht drauf. Ich denke, das wird sich im Wesentlichen auf eine Vermeidung der Vollkatastrophen äh drehen, dass sozusagen die Supermärkte irgendwie so mit dem nötigsten befüllt werden können auf irgendeiner Art und Weise, dass der Flugverkehr weiterlaufen kann und äh vielleicht einen eingeschränkten Maße halt auch der Tourismus.
Aber wo es halt,
glaube ich komplett zum Zusammenbruch kommen müsste, ist halt Finanzdienstleistung, das dürfte Großbritannien extrem stark treffen, die ganze Industrieaustausch im Prinzip fallen alle
britischen Unternehmen.
Pharma-Formelindustrie besonders digitalen Firmen, also Daten, Verkehr, die sind die, die ernsthaften Themenbereich.
Aber auch dieser ganze Online production, also diese Teilnahme an dieser Lieferkette, für komplizierte, industrielle Vorgänge, insbesondere halt den Automobilbereich
und das würde ja dann auch dazu führen, dass dann halt die Paar äh Automobilwerke, die es halt in äh UK noch gibt, die könnten ja maximal für den lokalen Markt produzieren so. Also Nissan, et cetera, aber das sind ja auch Kapazitäten, die dort haben, die ja nicht nur für den,
britischen Markt gedacht sind und wenn dann auch erstmal Krise ist, dann kauft ja auch nicht mal mehr irgendjemand ein Auto.
Genau. Aber aber alle Verbände schreien
ja, nicht nur den, sondern sieben, also die Hauptverbände, die sind diese Mannfakturindustrien, die die, die Supermärkte ähm
wie heißen die, die British Retail Consortion, denke ich, äh, ja, heißen die.
Die schreien ja alle bitte unseren Sorgen ernst nehmen. Ja,
und das Einzige, was die Regierung so sagen kann, ist ja, wir machen eine Werbekampagne, damit alle diese Industrie wissen, was los ist, ja,
Also man kann nicht die komplette Verantwortung für diese Situation auf den Schul. Von von diese Industrie verschieben. Äh es ist vollkommen verantwortungslos.
Aber das ist fast die Regierung gerade tot.
Es, es ist die kümmern sich nicht um den Details, es ist Brexit zur Zeit zu jedem Preis. Und um für die Zusammenhalt der Konservitiven Partei zu sorgen.
Die Frage, wie lange die alten Feindbilder, mit denen dieser ganze Brexit-Prozess äh angetrieben wurde, noch halten können.
Das stirbt schon ein bisschen, die in die britische Debatte. Ja, also, das ist es hat irgendwie an.
Es ist irgendwie nicht so ernst irgendwie. Das ist das ist es treib nicht den Menschen so ganz wie wie.
Wie vor Weihnachten.
Und einfach mal, dass dass man gesehen hatte, dass mehr Kooperation mit die EU in Sachen Gesundheitspolitik jetzt sinnvoll sein, ja sagen siebzig Prozent oder so, der Bewirkung, ja.
Auch Brexit-Befürworter, ja, wo das ein bisschen an der irre ist. Aber weil die genau gegen sowas gestimmt haben, ne. Aber so, ja. Also die.
Bei Chancen sind selber stand auch vor ein paar Tagen vor der Kamera und hat darum geworben, dass Leute aus der EU dann doch nach Großbritannien kommen und dort zu arbeiten, weil sie halt die Arbeitsplätze brauchen, da dachte ich ja auch irgendwie fast in aller Welt.
Jetzt ab. So.
Ja, wir weil die haben versucht, die haben diese Pick Brit Pick für British Farm, so hieß das ja, okay, Kampagne gegründet, ja. Also das britischen Arbeitslosen gehen zu den britischen Bauenhöfer und und und,
ja
Lasst mich raten, da hat's super funktioniert.
Überhaupt nicht.
Funktioniert, ja? Niemand will das machen, ja. Und dann die, die sozialkonservativen, ja, so auf den echten AfD-Milchflügel, der Konzert, die Partei. Aber das ist nie stakzeptabel, also wir müssen die Menschen verpflichten auf den Bauen, Höfe zu gehen, im Moment mal,
wir sind in einer sehr gefährlichen Situation hier, ja, pass auf, ja? Äh habe Johnson,
Johnson ist nicht so otoritär selbst, ja. Äh aber die die Tweets sind die, die die Werbungen für für diese Compay, meine Gute,
Ja? Äh er sucht die mit viele Fahnen und und tut was du tust für für deine nationale Interesse und auch meine Güte.
Wie im Krieg.
Ja ja.
Ja, John.
Ich glaube, das war jetzt erstmal wieder schöner Ausblick. Es ist wirklich einfach unfassbar. Was da abgeht. Ich denke, das ist auch in der EU.
Also auch, sagen wir mal, deutsche Perspektive, wir haben ja gerade andere äh Sorgen, man weiß zwar irgendwie, dass sich da was zusammenbraut, aber es äh könnte noch ganz sportlich werden, weil im allerschlimmsten Fall.
Haben wir dann sozusagen nach den USA nochmal so ein Feld direkt dann auch noch vor unserer Tür, wo einfach gar nichts mehr so richtig äh zu laufen scheint und,
was weiß ich auf einmal Kerpakete nach Großbritannien schicken muss oder so, das ist.
Aber irgendwie ist es irgendwie also Schlusswort. Dominik Hammings.
Und die Leute waren immer ein Schritt vor das britische Volk in Sachen Brexit. Die haben.
Das so gesehen, verstanden, dass so so richtig spielt und das war klug geliefert.
Bei Choronoviros ist genau den Gegenteil.
Viele Briten haben begonnen, sich zuhause zu isolieren, vorerst überhaupt Pflicht war.
Dass es hier jetzt schlecht geht oder dass die Locherungen so schnell kommen in Großbritannien. Ja, vor Großbritannien alles wirklich im Griff hat, ja? Mit Corona. Oder mit dem A Porto mit Kontakt, Tracing.
Die Briten ja haben Angst und bleiben.
Mehr Zuhause. Ja, die Regierung sage ich ja, ja, bitte, so kann den Arbeitsplatzen und die Leute sein hier im Moment mal, pass auf.
Also was bedeutet das, man hat den einen, die Regierung, renn jetzt hinterher, irgendwie. Und das ist ja interessant.
Und wenn die Regierung dann hinterherläuft, ins Auto, in Sachen Brexit, oder dem wirtschaftlichen Wiederaufbau des Landes, ja? Wir.
Man sieht viele sehr interessanten Entwicklungen,
Die ganze, die große Frage ist, wie gehen die dann aus? Lernt die Regierung von dieser Situation? Ohne doch nicht, denn dann könnte es dann sehr schnell so eine sehr, sehr gefährliche Fail State-Situation,
aber da erweckt man ein soziales Zusammenhalt, was.
Jahrelang nicht der Fall war und wenn Brexit überhaupt nicht der Fall war, das.
Wir Leute, die auf dem Insel wohnen, wir sind ja irgendwie zusammen. Hat uns alle betroffen. Wir sind zusammen. Und die Ausnahme ist die Regierung.
Also es ist ja nicht selbstverständlich, dass alles sturzt. Es.
Politisch wird's schlimm sein. Ja, jahrelang. Da bin ich sicher. Aber irgendwie, man sieht Würzeln, kleine.
Beginnen von einem etwas anderen Gesellschaft in Großbritannien, ja? Also da gibt's einen gewissen Hof.
Das ist gut, dann können wir den Podcast mit etwas Hoffnung abschließen. Vielen Dank schon.
Ja. Ja und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's hier bei äh UKW heute mal zum Thema Brexit.
Geht aber auch bald wieder weiter mit ein bisschen mehr Chorona, das lässt sich alles noch nicht ganz äh vermeiden, ist aber auch noch spannend genug. Weitere Themen hoffe ich dann in der Zukunft auch aufgreifen zu können. Bis hierhin, sage ich erstmal. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.